This is Jocko podcast number
90 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
Okay.
As my wife,
Tori mentioned this past week has been
in one of the most challenging of my
life.
I want to say thanks to my friends
and family for your support.
You really have no idea how much a few
words of encouragement can mean when you
are at a time and place like this.
Thanks again.
My platoon isn't a very active area
of operations in southern Afghanistan.
Our mission is to close
with and destroy the enemy.
Yeah.
There is no outside the wire
here because there is no wire.
My boys are simply always on alert.
We haven't had a shower since
we've been in Afghanistan.
Yeah.
We've run nonstop missions and have been
very successful at accomplishing these
without experiencing
any injuries to our own.
I'm just trying to paint a picture of
life here and not trying to make you feel
sorry for us.
Yeah,
trust me.
I belong here with these
guys and we are a family.
Rather.
I want to paint a picture because I'd
like to tell you about Travis mills.
I know you don't know him,
but it would mean a lot to me
to be able to spread his story.
My platoon string of missions without
injury came to an abrupt and violent and
last week when we hit a dismounted
IED during combat operations,
I had three paratroopers
injured from the blast.
Yeah.
One was minor,
one was severe
in one was simply beyond words.
The most severe injury was sustained
by my weapons squad leader,
Travis.
Big Mills.
I'd like to take the opportunity
to tell you about them.
Even under the conditions that I've
described. He is the best of us.
Yeah.
He was the biggest guy in the platoon
and has the biggest heart to go with it.
Yeah.
He was eager to please
and always cheered us up.
Yeah.
He led from the front and
was injured because of it.
He preferred that he take the
injury over any man in his squad.
He was the most fearless person
I have ever seen in combat
when we weren't in combat. He
was great to have around. You.
Woke up every morning and saying
a bunch of different songs to us.
Usually Keisha or Britney spears or
the songs of some other girl band.
We had this ritual. Anytime we finished
a patrol where we had a firefight,
once we returned to the strong point,
he'd run to the front of the formation
and sing songs about the 82nd airborne.
He would do dance gestures and all.
He even did it for the brigade
commander when he came to visit.
It was a big hit.
I laughed at how are he laughed at how
serious I am and how I don't like to be
touched.
So he made it his personal
mission to make me laugh.
Usually this involved an overly aggressive
and a little too intimate man hug,
followed by a middle school style
dance where he'd grind on me.
Yeah,
he kept me sane.
I laughed at his antics constantly
in combat. There is no one we
would rather have been with.
He risked his life to
save all this constantly,
and I can recall two times specifically
where he literally saved me.
Needless to say,
I took his injury hard,
including the personal guilt
that'll leader feels when
he is responsible for his
men.
So I wanted to tell you these things.
Everyone is asking how I'm doing.
Yes,
I am hurting.
Yeah,
but you know I'm going to be okay.
More importantly,
Travis is going to be okay.
The truth is obscene things here,
so terrible that I'll never be
able to put them into words.
Travis injury being at
the top of the list,
but I've also seen things
here so wonderful that I'll
never be able to put them
into words either.
Yeah,
I know that sounds crazy,
but it's true.
How do you put into words the spirit,
like the one I've just
described in big mills,
the reality of it is that I have the
honor of leading people like Travis.
Yeah.
There are many more in
my platoon just like him.
So while I've seen some things I'd
like to never talk about again,
I've seen just as many that I'll spend
the rest of my life trying to explain to
anyone who will listen.
I've seen a tremendous love and care
between brothers that have only each other
to rely on
and have only one care
to bring each other home.
It's a selfless,
deep,
everlasting bond that I consider myself
lucky and absolutely privileged to be a
part of.
Thank you so much again for your support,
but know that I am fine.
I am exactly where I need to be right now.
My family here is taking care of each
other and we will persevere as one.
Oh
now that
is a
letter that was written to friends and
family at home from Lieutenant Zack
Lewis,
commander of First Platoon Bravo troop.
Yeah,
473rd Cavalry Squadron,
Fourth Brigade Combat Team of
the 82nd airborne division,
the all Americans
and I think that letter describes staff
Sergeant Travis Mills as only a fellow
platoon member could
explaining is unbelievably
positive attitude.
There's courage under fire
and is on wavering leadership
and tonight
I am honored beyond words to have the
man that Lieutenant Lewis spoke of Travis
Mills here with us to talk through
his experiences on the battlefield
and off.
Travis, welcome to the show. Good evening.
Thank you for having me. Yeah.
Now I'm going to say this upfront.
I was a little nervous about having you
on because this show has a reputation of
being very serious
and very solemn.
And I know that you have an issue
with both of those terms in a broad
perspective.
So for those of you that haven't
heard anything from Travis before,
okay.
There's not a lot of serious stuff
that Travis does, so, um,
serious comedian and hilarious
guy with an incredible attitude.
Um, welcome to the show, man. Thanks
for coming on. Thank you so much. I'll
do my best to be serious.
Um,
I think my ltd described it very well
in that letter he wrote to his family.
I made sure that I kept their spirits up
and I would hug him and everything like
that. But under fire it was a
whole different person. Yeah,
yeah. No, I thought he did a
great job of capturing, you know,
what everyone's feeling over there. And
I didn't, I didn't go in Afghanistan,
but what does the similar to what
we'd fill in Iraq. Um, and you know,
I talk about this a
lot about the fact that
this is why guys miss combat.
You know, you miss combat,
even though it's when you're over there
and you're in this crappy situation and
you're like, oh, I can't wait to get
home. But then when you get home,
you have that little thing in
the back of your mind that says,
that misses that comradery,
which only comes from that place.
So he did a good job of describing that.
So
I think to,
to understand where a man ends up,
we kind of got to understand
where a man comes from.
So going back to the beginning,
the young Travis mills,
the young Travis Mills, and you know
how you grew up in all that. Um,
talk a little bit about that.
Yeah, I'm a, I'm from Michigan.
When I go around and I speak
throughout the nation and I always say,
is anybody from Ohio before? I
tell him permission and I yell, Oh,
H and then they yell io and to get
real passionate and then I yell sucks,
you know? And I get, I get some booze,
but I'm from a small town in Michigan, um,
right around the film area. I grew up
playing football, basketball and baseball.
I have an older sister
and younger brother. Um,
my parents are phenomenal people and
you know, just good, wholesome values.
And then I went to college
and play football, uh,
after high school was over and decided
that probably wasn't the right time for
me to go to college and take it serious.
So I went to the,
hold on. So you were playing
three sports in high school and I,
I got a quote from your book in here
by the way. Um, I'm going to read it.
Yeah.
I was the fun kid who lived
at the end of your block.
I was big for my age and for a lot of
boyhood years I had a big gap between my
two front teeth. Yup. Now
is that a negative thing?
Um, no, not at all. Okay.
Because some of us at the table,
you're still have a gap between
our phones. I'm just saying. Oh,
I on the sides now, right?
Yeah, I do. But I, uh,
I like to wear my hair,
my hair shaved and a buzz cut,
particularly in the summer is when it got
hot with that opie Taylor kind of look,
I fit into small town America.
And you did karate,
by the way.
You're looking at the 1993 create
a cry state champion. I Michigan,
I was six.
But that's,
it's not a competitive age
bracket for karate champion chess,
spinning back kick kids right
over at rest on that breaking.
Uh, actually you had, you had
a contest here. I'm going to,
I'm going to read about it.
It wasn't all easy.
And one of my first karate matches,
I got kicked hard in the
sternum and couldn't breathe.
I gas panic and tried to suck air when
my normal breathing didn't return.
Immediately I raised my hand
and forfeited the match.
I'm kind of disappointed my dad rushed
over. Travis, what are you doing?
You forfeit the match.
You,
you never forfeit the match no
matter how hard you're hurting.
You never quit ever.
Yeah. My Dad was disappointed in me
too. Yeah. So I never did it again.
And then I just, I dunno, I just went
hard the rest of that after that, I just,
I don't know. My Dad taught me good
values. My mom took karate with me. Um,
so don't mess with your mom
either. No. No. Wow. Yeah.
She's, she's five foot two, 125 pounds.
How did, how did she produce your big ass?
I don't know. I don't know. That was your
dad a five. 11. No kidding. Yeah. Yeah.
But I was six foot three when I was
at my walk around weight and, uh,
the first match I ever had,
I had a girl and she beat
me cause I wouldn't hit her.
And then I was cleared to like hit
girls and I thought that, okay,
so the next year I thought it
went, went to town on, you know,
just put a weapon and now I know you
don't hit girls either way. So I learned,
you know, that's a lose,
lose situation. But then your
mom, your mom told, you know,
go hit her. Yeah, that's what it is in
the book. Like she was like, hey listen,
you got to go beat her up. Well, okay.
So it was competition and she was in my,
you know, they didn't have
the separate gender brackets.
So everybody was the same.
And the first girl I faced,
I wouldn't hit and I lost about,
and then the next girl after that,
my mom was like, you can, you can
hit them. And I was like, oh, okay.
So I was just like, you're
going down. And I went after it.
Oh, that's jacked up, man. I was sick.
So I mean, I hadn't, yeah. You know,
puberty and everything he didn't hit yet.
That was seven for me.
The uh, football team, Vince Laville.
Did I say that right? I love, Yay.
Okay, well, you know, don't worry about so
much of a French speaker over on my end.
Oh, whatever that language is. If I know
his name, I would've said the same thing.
Here's how he described you.
The first time I met Travis,
he was in middle school at track meet.
I had heard about him.
So I went over to watch him. He won the
shop put, which meant she was strong.
Then he ran over. Then he ran over to
the 100 yard hurdles in one though too,
which meant she was fast.
You don't see that combination a lot.
I knew that this kid was going to
be a special athlete in high school.
He became a superstar three sport athlete,
baseball, basketball and football.
He was the leader on each team and made
first team all conference in all three
sports with football. He was definitely
a big cog in our teams. We'll,
we're the smallest school in our
conference and we got beat up for a lot of
years,
but his junior year,
Travis and his friends got
into weightlifting and power
lifting and went to all
the football camps.
That year.
We won the conference championship and
made the playoffs for the first time ever.
Travis has work ethic moded
everybody motivated everybody.
Everybody got stronger because
Travis was their leader. Jack
and steal.
What champions do first time we ever made
to play off. How did you, how did you,
what like got you. What made you start
lifting a coach? When I was in seventh,
sixth or seventh grade, he said that
after school, if I wasn't playing a sport,
I had to go lift weights and he was
the vice principal, the high school.
So having friends in high places is
nice because when you get in trouble you
don't really get in trouble,
you know? Um, the story.
Yeah. The story in there about me getting
in trouble in class freshman year.
Where'd you do? Uh, I don't really,
I broke a childish, nevermind,
but just tell us what you did.
It's in the book, you know, my buddy
fired in class, got kicked in the hallway,
so then my other buddy did,
so I wanted to go out there.
So I finally let one rep so I can go out
in the hallway and he took us into the
office, but he just said, guys, knock
it off. You can't do this anymore.
Which protein? Powder. Oh, that's
all. Yeah. So my buddy Eric,
he got his parents are very competitive
like mine were and we were the both the
team captains and stars of the show, if
you will. So I went home and said, hey,
can I get some cell tech and nitrile tech?
And it was before they had the rally reg
regulations on it and my parents like,
no, you can't do that. I'm like,
well Eric's parents let him get it.
Maybe it wasn't true.
Right.
Eric went homes at the same thing to his
parents so we both got to get on those.
And then, I mean, you
know, protein powders,
it's often that's going
to disrupt science class.
But no, I mean it was, it was
fun. You know, everybody, I
worked at a grocery store,
um,
after the football games,
the old man would come in and drink
coffee and hang out with me and my boss.
Just like the owner.
The storage is accepted it like the wives
would shop and you get away with it.
Yeah. As at the water cooler. Bowser
coffee pot and we just hang out.
Tell me what I did wrong.
I did write very varsity
varsity blues town. Big Time. Yeah. Yeah.
I saw some video footage of you at those
games and it was like madness at those
games. We'll have the one, the one run.
I had looked pretty good on film. Yeah,
look pretty good to me.
It was one time I did anything special.
So you get done with your
senior year of football.
And Did you maintain the high level of
discipline in your grades after that
point?
No,
actually I broke up with a
girlfriend that has a 4.0.
So my grades went right down.
No more steady partner. No,
no more like she would help do homework.
Yeah.
Be in the same class and write lefthanded
for the scratch work and hand her to
me. Nothing like that. And so that,
that meant, did you get looked at, did
you get looked at for college ball? I did.
I had a couple offers for
baseball and football. Um,
D two couple of d one smaller d ones.
And for some reason my guidance counselor,
he just,
I think he just knew Mr. Sampson,
great guy.
He kind of figured I wasn't going to
like college and be disciplined enough.
So he's like, what about this community
college? They're really good. Um,
you can go there and play football. And
I, and I decided to go there and, uh,
I just,
I mean if I was cut off from football,
I wasn't cut out for this study in there
at that, at that time in my life. Right.
And so you went there for what? A
one year? A semester. One semester.
And my girlfriend was like,
you should move home.
So I did and I met her
boyfriend, Collin. So then,
then I joined the army. He moved
back in my life. How did this happen?
It's her fault. I have no one to
call him lately. I haven't talked.
I haven't, you know, we
all look him up. I mean,
he worked at a popup golf course
and I found everything out.
So I grabbed my buddy up and went over
there and the manager of the place,
like sent them home. Why'd she tell you
to come home? Chill. I can be by her,
I guess. I don't know. And then I
was like, Hey, what's this about?
And then she finally broke down
and told me. So I was like, oh hey.
Did you know the army was taken
people and give them bonuses. See Ya.
Cause you were in debt,
you ran up, you know,
it was about 10 grand in
debt for community college,
but that was for the whole year. The
baseball coach asked me to play there too.
Um, yeah. But then you,
uh, you're in debt. You're,
um, Collin wisdom on the scene
now that kind of threw a loop.
So you end up joining the army.
I joined the army,
I went to all the recruiters and
the army had the best thing going,
which was cash, $24,000.
That money's at today.
No idea. Does, did Budweiser
get any of that money? You know,
now I don't, I'm actually, I'm
not a beer. Not a boozer. Whoa,
Whoa, Whoa, whoa. No, no, no, that's
not go that far. I'm a whiskey fans,
but uh, no. I mean I just, I
saw a way to pay my bills back.
I saw a way to travel and
do some more fun stuff.
I went in there to be an electrician and
they show me airborne video. I was like,
I want that. Oh yeah, deal. Deal.
What's that called? Bait and switch.
But I really want to do is I want
to get a good thing, you know,
where I can carry on in the civilian
life and have a good trade that you have
that I can play back to the civilian
world. They're like, watch this video.
You're like that.
That's me.
Is it like airborne recruiting
video? Um, well to be honest with Ya,
I was a ranger regiment recruiting
video and I signed up for all that.
But then all the rumors were like if you
don't make it, you're going to Korea.
And I'm like,
I don't want to go to Korea.
And then 22 of my friends went to Fort
Bragg cause you got to pick your duty
station because they were filling up
the new brigades and they're like,
oh you guys, we need you to fill in
here and you can pick where you go.
So all of us from basic training went
cause what year was this? 2006 Oh yeah.
So that's,
so that's totally different from me
because I joined the navy in 1990 oh yeah.
That was before I was even a Christ
a champion. We're talking old school.
So there was no war going on.
And even though in my mind I always
thought like the seals were just like
fighting wars worldwide at all times,
which was not true. But I thought that,
but yeah, it wasn't like everyone
that was joining the military.
It's not like when you guys joined the,
your generation of people joined,
you knew you were going to war. Oh,
absolutely. 100%. You know, I, uh, the,
the biggest regret I actually do have and,
and not to kiss up to what you've done,
but it's not tried to go to the Rangers
or go special forces or to the see like
not even, I didn't even try
it. I wish I would have.
Well you would of w w did
you start thinking about
that further in your career?
Absolutely. Yeah. I was
going to come back, um,
and I was either going to a recruiter and
get my last year and a half of college
cause I went to college when I could.
I took college under enlistments and that
was going to try to go recruit her to
um, go ahead and get my degree and then
go to the special operations world.
Because if you don't do it that way,
if you become an officer lady,
you got to go back through
the queue and everything.
But it was either going to be go right
to a special operations and try that out
or go become an officer and then
go. But yeah, just uh, you know,
I dunno,
I have no excuses stuff for us.
It's a weird thing and I don't
really like anybody. Like I was,
if you compare you as an athlete in high
school and me and as an athlete in high
school, it's not even comparable. You,
you were like 10 times the athlete I was
for some reason I was stupid enough to
think like I can make it through that
training and you weren't smart enough to
go. Like, I can make that see the
gallery to, cause you would on this,
the saddest thing is with the whole,
uh,
the ranger contract I had and all these
guys were going and I got talked to my
buddies that go into Fort Bragg. I ran to
a bunch of them. They're like, oh yeah,
we made it. I was like, oh my gosh, I
could have this. It's an interesting,
it's an interesting, uh, it's actually
humility. It's you being like, hey man,
you know, I don't know.
I played, you know,
football and baseball and ran track or was
that, is that right? Well, a basketball,
football, baseball and
basketball. I'm a great athlete,
but I might not make it through that.
That's actually a form of humility,
you know, I think it is. I was just,
yeah, I don't know where her head was at.
I just, I, I, you know, looking back now,
I'm embarrassed about it
a little bit and I wish I,
I wish I would went and tried it out.
I mean, I live a really good life.
I have a wonderful life and everything.
Not to jump ahead.
A two beautiful children. So life life's
good. As bad as the situation. I'm,
you know, I found myself in in
April of 2012 but, but looking back,
I wish I would've tried something. Yeah,
yeah. I mean, but the 82nd airborne is,
which is where you ended up is
freaking awesome unit. Oh, I yeah.
I mean I drink the koolaid and
everybody's like, oh, about standards.
How'd you like,
and this is something that,
cause a lot of people that listen to
podcast, um, they joined the military,
believe it or not.
And like we just met a guy the other day
who's going September 18th going in the
Marine Corps. But I always want to tell
them like when you show up to bootcamp,
it's going to be a shock to your
system, right? I mean it is going to be,
you're going to lack of sleep. It's not
going to be stuff that you used to it.
It sounds like you've got a little,
you know,
shock to your system and you showed up
there of just normal military stuff.
And I guess my point in saying that is
when you show up to bootcamp who campus
is, is not going to be fun for you.
It's going to be a transition. I mean,
you can mentally prepare all day,
you know,
and then you get yelled at
and you're like, why is this
guy always yelling at me?
I didn't, I'm doing the wrong leave
me alone. Um, it made me eat coleslaw.
I don't even like Cole slaw. I mean, the
first thing I come out and they're like,
oh, well I guess Coleslaw
for lunch. I'm like, Shit.
So they put it on my slate and then
after I eat the Coleslaw you at first I'm
like, oh, he wants me eat this
for some reason to do this.
And then the next time at dinner and
I'm like, okay, finally. No. Cool.
So it's like military big bastard,
Jude eight first. I remember
you, you get to school goals,
so damn happy. Those aren't,
you know, so yeah. Yeah. That's uh, that's
boot camp, right? Yeah. That's okay.
I always thought when I talked to that are
going on, I'm like, just play the game.
Understand it's going to end and make the
army what you can make it like make it
work for you.
I understand the job you're getting
yourself into and things like that because
people ask, would you still join if you
know what happened? And I said, yeah,
absolutely I would. Um, I enjoyed every
second. I was going to be a 20 year guy.
I figured and I reenlisted
and, and uh, just,
you know. Yeah, it's cool. This is cool.
A thing that you wrote kind of as
you're wrapping up bootcamp, um,
you're thinking about September
11th, you know, like I said,
that for you is one that you clearly knew
that going in in 2006 and here's what
you said. I remember feeling a ragged mix
of emotions, anger, confusion, dismay,
and wondering why anybody
would want to do this to us.
I was American,
I understood we'd been attacked and
that our country was now at war.
And that when there's a war,
somebody needs to have the courage and
intestinal wherewithal to do the actual
defending,
fighting and unavoidable killing that
accompany military actions that would turn
out to be me.
And that's another thing that people need
to think about if you're doing in the
military. And I've gone through this with
a bunch of people that, you know, I, I,
this happened to be a long time
ago, this parent, you know, said,
can you come talk to my son and he really
wants to be a seal. And I was like,
yeah, sure, no problem. And so I
meet this kid strapping young kid,
look super happy and positive and he
does water polo and he's a great athlete.
And he's like, yeah, I really want
to do it in the seal teams. You know,
what advice do you have
for me? I'm like, are,
are you ready to kill people
and are you ready to die?
And it was like the whole room got just
them two but they're looking at me like
I'm crazy.
But my point was like,
that's what the military is. You kill
people and you risk your life. That's,
that's what the military is
mean. Yeah, absolutely. They have the
combat and noncombat a combat mos is,
you know, just in every of your service.
So with the seal teams, with the infantry,
that's, that's what your job is and
you're willing to risk your life. Um,
for others. I mean it's just when
I signed up I was like, yeah,
I'm ready to do this, but you're
never really understand everything.
And then when you go through
basic training and they
show you all these videos
and a lot of it, they showed a
lot of band of brothers stuff,
which is what got me interested in
going into the military. And um,
I just took it as like, this is what I
is what I'm born to do. This is awesome.
Yeah. But when I get what you're
saying and then people ask me,
can you talk to out of doing this?
And I'm like, no, no, you can't.
You can't talk yet. Poor a young
man out there doing this stuff.
Find people that want to tell you
like, well, I was going to join.
But then I did this and I'm like, I
don't, I don't care. Like don't, you know,
and everybody I talk to, not
everybody, but that's what I talked to.
They got to give me their worst
story possible. I was like, oh,
I got a brother who's a friend that
lost two legs, you know, in a bear trap.
And I'm like, okay, so I know what
you're going through. I don't.
Okay.
That works for me
I guess. Do you got to watch out for
them? Bear trap. Sneak up on you.
My brother's friend was crazy. I met
him one time. When I get what you're,
I know exactly what you're
doing. I'm like, oh, okay dude.
Uh,
this cracked me up.
You're at airborne school most
you're doing your first jumps.
Do five jumps at airborne school, most
back to the book most without incident,
except my third jump,
which was supposed to be a daytime combat
jump with full gear on the way down.
I dropped my rucksack too slowly.
You're supposed to release it
when you come to the tree line.
But when I released the packet,
stayed just ahead of me and I landed
on top of the metal frame frame. Ouch.
I yelled in pain.
The jump master was already on
the ground and yelled back at me,
did you bring something
private mills? I said, no.
He glared at me and added then shut up.
I showed up
airborne schools.
Really funny.
And so this is what happened to me at
airborne school. I was a first for review.
I'm not like I'm,
I,
I'm a person that falls fast
through the air when parachuting.
I don't know why I'm just one of those
people float though. I don't flow. And,
and the other thing was I
didn't like doing a PLF,
which is the proper way to land,
which is you keep your feet and knees
together and then you like act like you
have one big leg and that's the way you're
supposed to prevent getting injured,
breaking your ankle or knee or whatever.
And so when I was parachuting at Airborne
School, I wasn't really doing a PLF.
I was just kind of athletically
landing on my feet, right? So anyways,
they got these loudspeakers
down on the, on the, uh, field.
And as all these new guys, all of us are
just new. And the guys on the megaphone,
he goes and he's talking to me because
my feet are apart and I'm just going to
do an athletic cleaning, goes feet, knees
together, feet together, a bone feed,
knees together on the street, names
together, a burn. Y'all write airborne.
So, uh, yeah, I thought that was funny.
Is that correct? Did it hurt? No,
I didn't get hurt. That's impressive
to get hurt because you got, you know,
I was a,
I was actually a jump master dart towards
the end of my military time that was
in and you know, got the balls of
feet, calf, you know, I had it all day.
You had dialed, oh, those instructors,
how long has the jump master school to
be an instructor at Fort Benning? Well,
Admin, so it's completely different. So
it's not that much different I guess.
But for me it was like a three week course
and I was able to like check people's
equipment, but they didn't
make you memorize the Turman.
Oh, they did. Did, did they?
Uh,
you got to memorize like the pre jump
brief and everything and stuff like that.
But no, like, like this is a nylon
stitch with 5,000 grain testing.
Steel is stronger than America, so he
doesn't no way stronger than in America.
No Way. But no, they don't. They
don't do that to you. That's a,
that's a good good
times.
Um,
you're getting ready for your first
deployment to show up at 82nd. Everyone,
you're, you're there, you're getting
ready for your first deployment. You know,
you're going to Afghanistan and you're
leaving just after Christmas and here or
go into the book.
My Dad didn't to me about leaving
over the next few days. We hung out
and did whatever we normally did,
but most he said during that time
was be sure to keep your head down.
Then the day before I left, Dad told me
a story about when he went into the army,
he taken washable paint and written a
note to his parents in their shower stall
where they were sure to be able to see it.
It said one short sentence of reassurance.
All will be fine.
Early in the morning that I left,
I took a washable marker and went into
my parents' bathroom right above the
faucets where they were sure to see it.
I wrote the same short message.
All will be fine.
I was miles away from the house.
When my dad called,
he told me he saw the note,
I didn't say much and he didn't say much.
He told me he loved me.
Then his voice became hoarse and his
words of support for me came out,
broken and choked.
First time going on deployment.
And it was, it was a little rough too
because I'm a guy from my hometown,
a marine. Uh, he was a buddy of
mine. His Dad was my baseball coach.
His brother was in my grade and the
day after Christmas on the 26th,
he got shot by a sniper in Iraq and
ended up right to his heart and he didn't
make it home. So his, uh,
my brother's actually,
his girlfriend was his,
uh,
Chris is a little sister and she was
at my house and I found out from,
from friends that what had happened before
the family found out from people that
were deployed with the unit. So, I mean
that was, that was rough on my parents,
you know, to have me, you know,
in a couple of weeks going overseas and
then I'm at home the day after Christmas,
you know,
a guy gets shot that I know.
Yeah, there's uh, um, it's one,
I think that's one of the
hardest things for a win.
Win military families see
someone wounded or killed,
they know that that could be their,
their loved one. And that's why that,
that's, I mean a days before you're
leaving, man. That's, that's harsh.
And, and then we're good.
We're close friends with the
family. Like, like I said,
his dad coached me from I
think 10 years old, up to 14.
Yeah, 14 or 15, but you know, knew
the family, are they? Well, so,
so it was a little rough and things
like that for a bit, uh, on my parents.
But you know, people now when
they see me, they say, Hey,
do you go and speak to a lot of
military things? And I'm like, you know,
I don't really do that that much.
If they want me to come in I will,
but I'm not sure. But guys are going
overseas want to see me on stage saying,
hey guys, you're going to be
a okay. You know, I'm yes,
try not get her out. I mean,
I mean I talked a lot of companies but
when it comes down to that I'm like,
hey guys, you'll be good over there.
It's like some movie that that six uh,
I don't know it is, but they're like maple
tree made me the man I am today. Yes.
Yeah, I've never seen it. Mega told that
line and he's got like two fake legs.
He's good. He's real good with
movie quotes, especially bad movie.
I'm so glad I forgot you were here.
No, it's great. Now and then chime in
here. So your first
deployment, what are you,
are you in the e three Ernie
for? Um, when I went over there,
I think I was in e three. That's, I
might have been an easy to actually,
am I personalizing, I was only in the
military like six months where I deployed.
That's, that's crazy. I was a good time.
I worked for a colonel basically PSD
for the kernel, right? Yeah. Yeah.
So like try me and like a young private,
you go to a unit that's not an infantry,
you don't get treated like
crap. You work for a, uh,
lieutenant colonel who was a direct
descendant of colonel Custer. He's, uh,
it was his great uncle and the guys
just as wild Scotty d and he always walk
around and see what's better than
a pair of vases, guys to pair.
And he show like the double A's on
his own and a phenomenal guy really.
And we just go around with them.
So we ever got yelled at or my,
my team leader was, was a
cook sergeant rush. Like if
we, if we ever got yelled at,
he just go to the colonel and be
like, hey, so they're bothering us.
And in the crumby be like, don't
even talk to my guys. And I'm like,
this is so nice. Being protected
sign. Literally a colonel.
So that was a relatively
Kush. And you were living on
a, if you're with a colonel,
I'm assuming you were living in like
pretty good fom Salerno. Oh yeah.
And they have like hard
buildings and they had tents.
We were in the very first hard building.
Oh.
We all went in and bought a satellite
Internet. I had a shower every day.
Hot meals. It was a wonder if, how often
are you rolling out into town every day.
Okay. But we'd go out to government
work and come back, you know,
and then I was in the gym.
I'd go eight o'clock.
I don't like being in the gym with
people. Like I was like, I don't know,
none of my machines.
And I super set it a lot.
So I'd go from eight till 11 at night,
just crush it. And then midnight child,
which is like the greatest thing ever.
Yeah, no crowd. Oh, you just, you're like,
I'll like omelets and hot wings.
Oh,
you get the Combo breakfast and
dinner scenario booming down.
I know you're a much cooler guy than me,
but when you got the midnight child,
five sal, I'm telling you, it's
like, yeah, I went to the hot wings,
I'll take pancakes and,
and don't,
she doesn't take mashed potatoes
with gravy on that. And uh,
you guys, it sounds like on that first,
well you didn't, you didn't even shoot,
you even shoot your gun first
employee didn't have to,
I was on patrols every day.
I had a suicide bomber run out the house
and like detonated on the front of our
truck. Just like what an idiot. No,
I mean like, and like, you know,
it's nuts. Ax hanging off the light
and as you know, but he's just,
the truck's not hurting. It's like
genius Bro. Genius job. Well done.
A for effort. Yeah. Like a
F for judgment. Yeah. Yeah.
But still that, I mean that, that
having a suicide bomber hit your truck,
that's like, uh, that's at least a reality
check out a minimum. Right? Well, I mean,
yeah, so it was, it was our, our uh,
one of our front trucks and then also we
had a guy run up on the kernel opening
the hospital and detonate himself.
Um, I was in the truck at that time,
like in the gun,
but we just found out if we go out there
and we just make sure that everyone
knows, we're really aware. Every
time we take a turn, you know,
our guns are rotating, we're not
sleeping, we're up and out. Um,
we didn't really get messed with and um,
and that, and that helped. I mean, I was,
you know, I was in a place where
there was bombs and things like that,
but I was very protected,
you know,
dod would roll out before the colonel
went anywhere. Oh, that's right. Yeah.
How many guns, how many go on trucks
did you take on a convoy? Just portal.
Just four of us would have been the three
truck or two trucks. He was in the two.
I was just a hundred the first,
like six months. And then I was a,
I moved to like be a TC, but it, it, it,
the threat level was like medium. I
mean, cause you have to take it. Yeah.
You can take a bigger convoy
with more aggressive facilities.
If I was in the Hump, it was all Humvees
we were before, like any other there.
And I had a two, four, nine like is my,
my main weapon I had to saw. They're like,
yeah, okay. The front truck.
Yep. 50 cal a backdrop.
We're gonna give you a mark and you just
going to get a saw. And I was like, oh,
awesome. Thank you. So I had, I had
a saw. That's what I put it up there.
Like it was a big old gun. Yeah.
That's awesome. Good Times. Yeah.
Why didn't they give you a real
gun up there? Uh, apparently the,
my biceps were big enough. That was a
real gun show, you know, and I get that.
I had 22 at the time.
I got some supplements sent to me.
Respect SF guys found a way for me to
get some of their supplements. Wonderful.
Uh, no. Do you went to for, is this the,
is this deployment you went
for a home for R and R on?
It is and you had your first meeting,
first meeting with one of your platoon
mates, sisters, you know, I love it.
I love to antagonize people. And I
got in my space friend request and uh,
I thought, man, this must be a
dating Paige is it, you know,
cowgirl hat around blouse, shirt,
whatever, Jean skirt. I was like,
that's a dating site. You know,
there's an ad, wait a second,
that last name is Sam was my medic.
Let's do some investigation.
He was home and rnr and I was
looking through, I was like,
that's his little sister. She's 18
so it's legal. And I was just like,
except you know, and we started chit
chatting and I just did to make him mad,
you know,
but we ended up enjoying each other's
company the first time we ever met.
I was like, I just a vacation. I've been
here 11 and a half months, you know,
I got coming home for three for a 18 days.
You want, you want to go on vacation?
She was like, yeah, sure. So we decide
we're going to go to Cozumel, Mexico.
How'd you, how'd you talk to
her dad into that? She was 18,
so she knew what she wanted, I guess. I
don't know. He didn't kill me so heavy.
Right. And so you go to
Mexico, that's your first date.
Is that I'm just going to take you to
Mexico. Yeah. Yeah. You guys. I say,
I don't know that $24,000 when I know
exactly where, um, went to Mexico,
then back to Michigan for a week, had a
great time. Uh, she went back to Texas,
had to go back overseas. I got held up
in Atlanta, so I called her up, was like,
Hey, I'm in Atlanta for the night.
You want to come? And she said, yeah.
So she came out the next morning saying
our goodbyes crocodile to your streaming
from her face. Um, and she's like, I
love you. And I'm like, I'm no idiot.
So I love you too. You know, as fast
as I could. It's like, I love you all.
I didn't even pause. It's just like in
between her soft, I wanna marry you.
And I'm like, yeah, I
get that. But you know,
in my head I said that cause I was like,
I want to marry you to
real Casanova here, jump on that airplane,
get back overseas, give her a call.
Right. 24 hours later and Afghanistan,
I'm like, Hey, what's going on baby?
She's like, guess what? I'm like,
I don't know what weddings plans.
zales.com bought her a ring and called
her dad and whatnot and he living,
I guess that's cool. I'm like, well,
okay, thanks. And then we got married.
How did her brother feel about it?
Was he was her brother in your platoon
with you? I'll use my medic. Yeah,
he actually wrote in the same truck as
me am I colonel would pick on him on the
radio. Hey Buck, what do you think mills
is doing with your sister? And it's like,
I'm like breakfast break.
You can let that go because you mean
I'm standing up in the truck, you know?
And Josh can do hammer makes when the
back seat. And I'm like, no, no, no.
Don't do this. Don't do this
here. Um, but, uh, no, he,
he knew I was good guy. He's like, he
told his mom and dad, he's like, look,
I know how it looks. And he's
actually a good guy and really nice.
So we'll see how it works out. And
then I ended up marrying her. Yeah, no,
that's awesome man. That's a
great story. Do you detail it, um,
in here that it's pretty,
uh,
it's pretty unbelievable. You know,
that you pulled all that off? Well,
in the colonel was actually setting me
up to go to the prep school in Virginia
for West Point. He's like, you should
be playing football on my, my uh,
lieutenant at the time. Um, Lieutenant
Phillips, now he's a major but,
or maybe as a colonel now,
but, um, he was training,
he was a football coach and he
holds a record in Chicago. Yeah.
Most consecutive losses at the school
that he was coaching hat in high school.
Yeah. They were that
bad. Great guy though.
And he was like helping me coach and
train up and lift weights and do whatever.
But then I met Kelsey, I was like, I
be, I'm just going to do this, you know?
So we got married when I got back.
How long,
how long after you went home for
Christmas did you come back? Uh,
I came back in April and the 13th night.
14th morning.
And then you won't find it in my book,
but we got married at the courthouse
on the 17th. So there you go. Yeah.
And then we got married again and big
wedding junior like most miniature,
that money. Well, I needed to, I spent
all my money, you know, I was like,
I don't know how to get a house. So
I'm on, I'm like, look, we need to,
I need that Bh face during must've
favor with this damn wedding. You know?
So when you guys do your waiver in
Texas in Mckinney, about 112 that day,
and then, uh, did you say you settled
down and now you, now you know,
you're staying in the army,
you've pretty pretty much saying,
I'm saying the army at this point.
Well, I mean, I really enjoyed it.
I got moved around to another unit and
when I got back because I had to go to
like a line unit, couldn't be a PSD
guy. I mean I was up for it. I was like,
this is awesome. But uh, yeah, we've got
a house or an apartment in North Carolina,
uh, right outside Fort Bragg
there bought a dog. Um,
life was good and I figured the military
is doing well and then just kind of
hung out for 15 months or 18 months
before I deployed. I was going to say,
so it's 18 months between
deployments for you?
It was that usually a year and three
months. So like I went for 15 months,
so they gave me 18 months off and I went
for a year and then I, they gave me, um,
15 months off. Then I had to go again
for my third. But I'm jumping ahead here.
So you, you get back
over on deployment? Um,
yeah.
And this is, uh, this is like within
days that you deal type me up on that,
but one of your,
one of your friends,
Tyler Juden is saying that,
right? [inaudible] Yup. He's uh,
out on amount of patrol.
IED hits the first vehicle,
then they get a snarl small arms
ambush and I'm going to the book.
Here are guys needed to get the
disabled vehicle out of the way.
And while they worked
toward this objective,
Tyler sprinted up to a high sight on a
nearby hale and fired through some five
to seven magazines,
ammo protecting his soldiers below.
When the disabled truck was finally
cleared, Tyler sprinted back to the truck.
But the enemy had specifically targeted
him and RPG flew in and he was hit.
They rushed him back to the hospital
at the fob, but it was too late.
Tyler died on the operating table.
Yeah,
fury rose up inside of me.
I wanted to find whatever Taliban savages
did this to Tyler and shoot them in
the face.
Tyler was always cautious.
He took his job extremely
seriously and never made mistakes.
There was no reason for him to die.
He described to me once how he believed
his job as a sniper ultimately saved
innocent lives. He was putting into
practice what he knew to be true.
He was helping the world,
not hindering it,
and he'd been trained to be one of the
rough man who stands ready in the night,
prepared to do his duty, prepared to visit
violence on those who would do us harm
Tyler's death far hit far too close
to home and we'd only just arrived.
Yeah.
So that's not a fun way to
kick off deployment. No.
And I'm not sure if he's
experienced in your unit,
but it seems like the guys get hit are
the ones that you don't expect will ever
get hit. So Tyler was a year older than
me. Uh, I respected him. I mean it was,
it was crazy cause you know,
a guy's your older cycle or whatever,
but he had such a professionalism about
them and I looked up to him and I tried
to learn what I could from him.
And he only had like a,
he probably had an extra year and
a half in the army than I did, but,
but either way and highly ranked
sniper and a, he went up and just,
he didn't take bad shots, so he was just
popping everybody. They did Tyree him.
He actually, I'm pretty sure it was
a camp Chapman that he at the end,
not sure if you've ever been to the
SF. No, I haven't based there. Um, uh,
but anyway,
that's where he ended up not making,
there's only two weeks into the
appointment and um, you know, when,
when that guy like that gets hit one
you obviously frustrated and angry,
you don't know why it happened, but two,
it's like, well Geez, if he can get,
you know, hit or taken out, you know,
it kind of takes you down to competence,
integrity, a peg or two as well because
he's the guy you wouldn't expect.
Not that you expect anybody to
get hit I guess. But you know,
like a super soldier style guy.
Yeah.
Yeah. And I'm sure like everybody,
if you held them in that regard,
everybody held him in that regard and so
everybody's feeling that same kind of a
straight up nervousness, right? Yeah. And
there was, he would walk by like on our
ACU is I could have a strange pulls,
tuck the string in some standard stuff
if my way that would be hanging out and
he's what might yank on it and they
make you do pushups and yell at me and I
wanted to punch him in the
face but I couldn't, you know,
and I understood why he was doing it so
much is a fun story I guess I like tell
people cause I mean if I could've decked
him I probably would have only been in
one fist fight ever and knocked myself
out playing volleyball. That was it.
That was the one, yeah. It's sad
but true. It's in the book. Yeah.
I don't know what that really,
you might as well tell it.
Well yeah we just were playing volleyball
and I never got mad is going over the
net. We made [inaudible] for
like cables for the antennas.
We use those and five 50 cord and
it was like quick go over net.
I was six foot three and the net was
only six foot tall. So I was like,
just hammering it home. I had a
vertical, you know, like Lebron.
So he's ridiculous.
Whole belly button above the net.
And I kept going over
and they kept yelling.
So I pulled my hand back real fast for I
did it and I caught myself right in the
eye socket knocked out.
Do you actually knocked
yourself out? Yeah. Yeah. But,
but later on when I had this happen,
I didn't get knocked out.
Game engine with a fist of fury could've
done Floyd winter stood a chance
against me.
I don't know if I'm impressed,
if that's like super impressive
or super not impressive. Right.
You either have the office of iron
or glass jaw. We're not sure which.
I hit a bomb knocked out.
So my answers had been just of iron.
The questions have been answered.
Probably be in jail right now if I
went in fisticuffs with anybody. So,
uh,
you,
it sounds like you guys ended up
doing Overwatch's of a road in,
um,
what up bae?
Zach Pass. Okay. Yeah. And great time.
How long were you on that for? Oh, we
went out there and they were like, yeah,
just go ahead and pack for you know,
a couple of weeks.
And then we were out there
I think 57 50 days or so.
And we just live on top of a mountain.
And then like just monitoring the road.
Yeah.
Just cause they had a,
they were bringing up convoys that jingle
trucks with military gear on to build
another farb and we had people on
both sides. And I actually, uh,
I was so afraid to tell my wife I
went down one day and get some food or
something or get a resupply and uh,
I'm only back up. They made a stop.
They want to register mortars.
And I was like, what the,
I just want to get back up there.
I got out and I slammed my door
and like the brilliant guy am,
I went ahead and use a fist.
If you're in a hammer to homer and I
ripped the scab open on my hand and I told
the wife my story of my life, it was so
much blood, it was gushing was ridiculous.
But, uh, as my wedding ring
fingers, I took my wedding ring off,
put on the front of the Hummer and I got
the medic. I was like, get out your doc,
you know, Willis or whatever
have fixed this up for me.
And he had to put tape on it.
I got back in,
left my wedding ring right on the
front of that Hummer and drove back up
mountain.
So lakes for 37 days.
Every time I got a chance to go down
the mountain I was headed metal detector
out. Like please find
this tungsten ring please.
I don't want to tell my whole life
I you have in front of it.
And I,
I was like to give people that
didn't serve a little, you know,
impression or of of what it's like.
And I thought this one wrapped it up
pretty good. Going to the book here,
going so long without taking a shower
came with its share of complications.
Guys got trench foot from their feet being
wet and sweaty and not taking care of
them properly.
I got strange rashes in intimate areas
and it wasn't uncommon for a guy to
mutter about his balls sticking
to his leg when he hiked.
Every dude got chafed up pretty
badly in his bodily crevices.
And a common complaint
was that a guy had SLAs,
slang for sweaty ass.
My armpits hurt.
I sweated so much that the
salt got trapped in my skin
and my back broke out in
a raised bubbly rash.
This happened to other guys too.
The only solution is to get your ID card
out and have another dude scrape your
back hard until the salt crystals pop out.
It's a brutal procedure and it feels
like getting cut with a razor blade,
but it's all part of the fun
day to day,
day to day get.
So
I mean it sounds like I was complaining
to them that one, Huh? No. Yeah,
watching someone like scrape salt crystals
like size of table salt come out of
there. But I'm not sure
if you've ever experienced
anything like that. No, but uh,
yeah, that's pretty bad. And you
get so gross and then, I don't know,
I took four real showers out
here. Yeah, like real ones.
I mean you'd go get a water bottle and
poke holes in the top and spray yourself
down, but then you got to
get dirty all over again.
This whole long process or like how it
takes like nine days or something before
you get comfortable with
your nasty. Yeah. Yeah.
And then you don't even want to
break the cycle and get clean again.
Take you 90 days to get used to it again.
No, the best part, it's like the winter,
cause you don't smell
as bad in the winter.
Like when the winter you don't
take showers, you're like,
oh it doesn't even matter.
I brush my teeth keeping pearly white
teeth look whiter, you know? But uh,
yeah, no, it's pretty. I actually
decided I'm halfway into that deployment.
I was like told, my wife just sent
me eight pair range of panties.
So I wore a whole bear like range of
panties for a month and I just took them
off. I was like, no,
we're not gonna wash these just all more
here except it and move on 12 bucks.
Wellsmith so matter of fact,
whereas abs like past my, uh,
my pants got so torn,
they were like chats.
Like I bought chicks are hanging out
stuff and one of the sergeant majors came
in, you know, and they're all out of out
of shape. Like looking back at diction,
change brands. I'm like Sargent
Major. If I change my pants,
I'm gonna get another pair.
It looks just like this.
Like I'm not on the fob
and you come into like,
you got to get a new uniform and all that.
I'm like, bring me one. I'm like, yeah,
okay, let me do that.
You got it bud. I know.
Going to get back in that truck
and roll your ass out of here.
So back to the chicken wings and pancakes.
Oh,
I know a lot of Mras delicious.
Good Times. Yeah. You know I
gotta just straight up. I mean in,
in the seal teams we just don't GAF to
eat that many. Mrs is yet to
do the, either you make them,
you can make those things
delicious. Yeah, you can.
That burrito get at me makes
it a little bit in there.
Yeah. Uh, I actually, my
first deployment to Iraq,
we eight Mras for a little while and
I was legitimately sick of them and,
and it wasn't, it wasn't that long,
but I was already sick of them at one.
No 50 days. I can promise you that.
Yeah. Well I mean, yeah. Yeah.
You're just going to say something about
the seal teams weren't you? No, not,
I would never,
I don't have fiscal period defend myself.
So we're getting shipped in steaks,
crap like that.
I mean that later on that point we had
like steaks on like one day a week they'd
bring out like these frozen steaks and
we'd cook them over like an open pit of
fire with the stick through them.
Yeah. Dude is legit. Like I,
we'd go out to some rant,
my first and when we'd go out to,
cause we were living at, we on by op and
Baghdad, Big Chow Hall, everything good.
And we'd go out to do an op somewhere
to be some SF group in the middle of
nowhere and you'd see how they're living.
And it wasn't always an SF group or
someone's just an army, you know,
some Army platoon or company out there
in the middle of nowhere and you're like,
Dang, these boys are roughing
it nasty and we're here.
Like they brought Gatorade. They
bought a case. Give me too. Me Too.
I'm a hide one of my pillow case.
You'd feel bad. They did. Oh man,
you're in the seal teams are like,
dude,
I'm ashamed to do like even be
hanging out with you right now.
You guys smell so bad, but I don't
know why they brought me out here.
You guys go sit over there. We're
just gonna sit here. Leave us alone.
We'd hit guys. Do you know what? We've
gone three days without a shower.
This is crap, man. Yeah, we did that.
Let's totally the same life,
but in during this, I mean,
and during the shock is still like, it's
funny like my friends from high school,
right? I have two really good
friends, I can talk with whatever,
but if I run to another person
from high school or whatever,
we'll catch up on everything.
Then it's like,
oh great talking to you and you know,
and then you'd find a
way out the conversation,
but you run the military buddies you
haven't seen in years and you can just go
right back into it. You know, just
cause you understand where you've been,
where you're going through. Um,
speaking to going through stuff.
Here we go back to the book,
the Taliban screeched to a
stop and started shooting
at the amp bullets cracked
all around us. We got word
from higher command to engage.
I yelled to my men fire,
we shot our rifles and Schwartz let
loose with several bursts of machine gun
rat, a tat, tat rat, a
tat, tat rat a tat tat.
This is my first large scale
fire fight of any kind.
It hit me with a wham that this wasn't
really a training exercise anymore.
This was the real deal. My adrenaline
rose and way that a surge of energy,
but I also felt calm as if all my training
kicked in at once and I just did what
I was trained to do.
I honestly wasn't afraid.
I took aim and fired at the bad guys.
They fired at me and it didn't phase me
to think that I might kill somebody when
I wanted, when they wanted
to kill me first, I,
several Taliban members get hit
and fall more, fell and more.
The last few who are left turned around
and took off, took off up the wadi.
We got word to get not to
give chase because why?
These are great choke points for
a potential enemy and bushes.
When the shooting died down completely,
we approached close enough to see the
bodies of the enemy soldiers I just helped
to kill.
It was a surreal feeling,
but I reminded myself that this is
what a soldier's are built to do.
We receive reports later that three of
my men are three of the men killed were
top Taliban leaders in the region.
So there's your first gunfight.
Yeah,
it was pretty awesome.
So the a and p m AP commander was a
former Taliban guy and he switched over
sides and ran NP and he was like,
yeah, they're having a big meeting.
I got to call, they're going to come
down this Swati, we'll go check it out.
And then all of a sudden just like just
dropping, you know, Martin 19 and, um,
the 50 cal and two 40 on him and just
hey, you know, going nuts. And then, uh,
then, you know, they, they
come back and they, they,
they're really good about taking their
bodies away with them. You know, they're,
they're pretty good about it, but they
were like 18 or a 20 people deep in the,
in the wadi coming in. We just
led into him and uh, yeah,
that was my first like real taste
of like I shoot my gun at people.
What were you a team leader
at this point? Uh, no,
I was so I was actually a squad
leader. Oh, that's right. I was,
I was a position up so
I was still in e five,
but I was in a squad leader position so
I was trying to do is of what a weapons
squad? No, no, that we were actually, uh,
we were mounted. So I had my own truck,
but I had two tracks that were
under me, so I had to, to uh,
two trucks that were two teams.
[inaudible] had two team leaders that
were underneath me and then we each had a
truck.
So my senior like team leader had one,
he was a TC of his truck and then as a
TC of the junior team leader that, yeah,
that's a good time.
Again,
I said that it does speak in somewhere
or the other day and I said something
along those lines and
like somebody said like,
I think it's kind of weird that you say
it's good time and fun. And I'm like,
well, it's adrenaline rush. Like, yeah,
that's a good time and fun. I mean
they shot at me first and then
he started it.
Defend Yourself. But uh,
yeah, and then I mean,
yeah, it just, it doesn't, it didn't
phase me, it didn't hit me hard.
I wasn't worried about it. Um, just
kept moving on. It. Matter of fact,
that region died right down
like completely after that
if you kill all those bad
guys, they just in fact like a, that
was our first night out there too.
They moved out to the middle of nowhere
and the snow storm and I was like,
maybe I have not first night or second
night out there and we just shot
everybody and then for the next like two
months it was quiet and they were like,
they back filled with some
other platoon that like, hey,
we're going to bring you
in this platoon here.
You guys are going to go up north where
there's a lot of fighting in Baltimore.
God, all right, cool.
Let's do it. So that's,
that's the next big movement that you
made was that spot and that place had a
bad rep like as far as being
a lot of fighting there.
I bomb guy was real heavy,
real heavy. It was, I'm the bottom
of river. And when we got there, um,
the Italians were there before us and I
guess they were just like, hey, Taliban,
don't mess with us. Here's, here's some
money and we're good. And we're, uh,
we're the a second. So we're
like, no, not going to happen.
And the infantry platoon that we replaced,
I mean, for the record, I am infantry,
I was in a cab unit, but they always have
a Charlie troop is an infantry platoon.
They bring in and then we had these coin
between was always like two infantry in
two cab squads to make platoons up.
But um, yeah, we replaced these uh,
immature guys. They had two guys
killed, unfortunately fell into a river.
There's actually a ceasefire with the
Taliban defined the bodies and bring the
bodies back. Um, and we got
up there and there was like a,
a line in the sand. They said,
look, you cross this line,
you're going to get shot at. And we
were like, all right, cool. So we,
we started taking ground and um,
everywhere that there's a fighting
position on top of the mountain,
they would booby trap it when they
were done. So a guy, one of the Fo's,
Sergeant Fox, good guy, he picked
up a matchbox. It's like, Yep,
I got a matchbox it looks like. And then
just finally found his torso that was,
you know, everything else was
gone, just his body armor. Um,
but instead of staying
in one spot at this one,
we took one more spot and
they're like, yeah, well some um,
Marsac guys went up here
was these,
the strong points are corvette and impala
is that we're talking about now? Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. These are in your book,
you talk about those being an
impala was the, the even worse one,
even further into enemy territory.
Yeah. And they were like, yeah,
we had like a march. That guy got shot
in the head when he was up there. Um,
because there's like an eight man
team that went in there. Like,
you guys can't really go there. So we
decided one night we're going to go there.
We'd trained, we've got all ready for
it. Uh, what was the impala physically,
what does it like a little, uh,
former, like, like house or something.
It was actually absolutely as a house.
Um,
and we decided we're going to take it one
night because it was the last house on
the edge of town and then there was 1200
meters between the next like village
and the Taliban would go in there
and shoot at us and you know,
be able to sneak down away far
enough. And, uh, we had, um,
a javelin team come up on one side.
We went up in the middle of night on
this side and we had other people on this
side and we just, we just took it in the
middle of the night and then they said,
we're going to go up there for like
three days. Do we constantly come back?
And they're like, Hey, you know
what? We're going to stay there.
So the work didn't stop. We had to
fill sandbags, put up barbed wire. Um,
and then we went up the side of a
mountain and, and Doug in a, uh,
um, an LP, but it was like we had
21 guys or a tablet and never knew.
We only had 20 minutes a one man platoon.
So we had like 13 down at the cop and
then we'd sent the rest of them up on top
of the hill and we dug in so deep that
was eight foot deep pits and there was a
living room, uh, two 40
pit, a 50 cal pit, um, uh,
like a little dining kitchen area. And
then like three sleeping pits, like three,
like that two cots would fit in.
Like it was huge.
Did you put overhead cover
on them somehow? Uh, no.
We just dug them deep enough where
he didn't, didn't need it. Yeah.
I mean we put our, I guess we put our,
uh, um, ponchos over it, you know,
things like that. Not Protection
from mortars. No, no. Yeah.
And if you stood up when they were
digging it and they started digging it,
when you stood up and you were digging,
they start shooting at us.
And then we just rain hell. And, um, we
dug in and after about a month of that,
we just were killing so many. They just
gave it up. They're like, all right,
we're done. Um, and that's where
we, I mean, we can't, they came out,
we were black on water and then like
the brass came out. They're like, well,
why don't you guys shaven? Where's
your haircuts? I'm like, Hey,
we didn't have water. Are you
kidding me right now, bro?
And then at the same sergeant,
you're yelling for my pants.
They wanted to go up to cop. So my platoon
sergeants like, hey, sergeant middles,
I need you. Can you take one
of your teams and just go?
So we took four men out and I walked them
right over what I thought the road was
clear,
you know,
but it was all filled with water when
we took the place walking more huge IUTs
that just the batteries had died in them
cause they waited, we waited too long.
But when they're dried up,
like, oh, there's a mortar.
Oh look at that. That's it.
That's 18 mine and triple stack,
you know? Um, but anyways,
side would like took them up on top of
the [inaudible] and stuff like that.
And it was funny because as they're
yelling at us for not being shaven or
cleaned up,
I go according to the way up this just
like a hundred yards probably like I'm a
straight up and I go up a quarter of
the way with them and I said, all right,
I'll be right back. So I run to the
top and I'd say, Hey Lt, you know,
the sergeant major is coming up in
the kernel so just be ready, you know,
sort of like trying to put our uniforms
on and everything instead of like just
our tee shirts. And I run back down
and he's bear calling. He said,
sounds like I can't do it. I'm
like, no, eat your midnight child.
Childless us alone. How about
that? Are you kidding me?
Did he make it to the OPI? He made
it up to the top. He did eventually.
And I'm like, but I came back down. I
kind of put a little bit of fear in him.
I said, sergeant major, this is not the
spot that you want to stop right there,
that town that's Taliban held
anybody in that town's shoots at us.
And if they see that we're not moving
quick, they're going to take pop shots.
So you're gonna need to, yeah, I mean
mostly true. Yeah. And he's like,
he was like sitting down and looking
and I was like, no, no, no, no.
You need to need to move. Sorry to
make you need to go. And I mean,
and no offense to Nebraska,
it wasn't even my sergeant major.
I don't think that was there at the time.
It was like a different unit or whatever.
But, but yeah, I mean it was, it was a,
it was a wild, wild west. We were just
shooting, um, firefights everyday,
but we were the northern limit, you know,
there was no buddy farther posts, uh,
push to than us. Yeah. I want one
part. You're talking about how you,
you ended up shooting 11 javelins
in, in a day, I think. Yeah. That's,
that's getting after it on pretty
much anyone's standards. Yeah.
I think we shot 29, that whole
deployment. Um, it was, it was cool.
Damn. Um, so you conventional
army can be fun. Yeah.
Yeah.
Do the conventional army we were within
Ramadi were freaking getting after it
every single day is, they
were awesome. Awesome. Um,
like you were getting in a firefight
everyday there, huh? Um, or for a bit.
There we were and then it died right down.
They were just tired because you know,
once they shot once
we just, we let loose. We had enough
ammo to, to last us for years probably
and we let them know we'd let them know.
Yeah.
America's real cool when it comes to ammo.
Yeah. In those situations it's like, oh,
you guys need more. Yeah,
we'll be right there. Uh,
all right. You are. Yeah. Seem to
happen. You were like, you were like,
did you find you found triple
stacked ids in your position? Yeah.
So dumbest thing ever. We went in and we
cleared it and then we had like marines,
EOD,
like Marsac EOD clear stuff.
Like there was like an unexploded RPG
round in the side of one in the walls.
And then there was other booby traps
while it turns out where we were rolling
all of our big barrels for the
generator and stuff like that was like,
it was all bootstrapped, right. We're
exactly where we step. And this guy,
Sergeant Barton, he's a great guy. He,
there's this metal out of the ground.
He's like, Huh, what's that?
Starts beating on it with
a shovel. And I'm going,
I'm getting ready to go on my rnr Tang
and like, what are you doing dude?
Cause like some in the ground here,
just looking,
looking at it and started digging around.
He's like, oh, oh that's not oh shit.
And then it turns out we were on these
50 gallon drums taking all this supplies.
Oh, right over top, right in the
breezeway. God is where I would.
So it was so hot there. And uh, I mean I
get I racks out too, but it was so hot.
Like me and my buddy who was on
my, uh, team, uh, leaders, um,
would go out there and spare ourselves
as water. Bobby being our PT shorts,
sprays out of the water bottle,
lay on our cots and just
see how long it took to dry.
Usually about 10 to 15
minutes to get completely dry.
And our costs were right on
top of these just and no,
I do cause I mean EOD came
through and they didn't find it.
So was it,
you figure it was like a command debt
that had the battery died or something?
Uh, it was uh, yeah, well it was
um, a pressure plates. Oh my XO.
Like these big drums were having the
circuit connect but the batteries and I'm
dying, you know. Luckily we didn't take
the property to, you know, after like the,
I think after the march
that guy's got hit. Um,
they went in there and booby trapped at
all knowing that we were trying to take
it,
but somehow the batteries didn't work,
which helped out for us because we like,
we jumped over a rock wall that they had
where there's like a hole in the wall
ready from probably a hell
fire or something from time
before. So right where we,
you know, obviously be easy
place for us to jump over.
That's where we all jumped over and
there was stuff stack there too. So
it's where you talk about
it in here. Um, and,
and I heard this from the Vietnam seals.
They would set up ambushes
on VC and they would,
you know, go, okay, we're going to shoot
from here and when we shoot from here,
they're going to take cover
over here behind this lock.
So they'd put a big claim or one
underneath that log and there you're,
you're talking about how the Taliban
is doing the same thing over there. Um,
you know, basically, oh, we, as
soon as we start shooting at them,
they're going to run to
these covered positions.
So we'll just put booby traps your
minds in any of these covered positions.
Yeah, we actually had
to change up our, uh,
slps are standing operating procedures
on my third deployment and instead of
diving for cover, you had to
take a knee. Yeah, that's,
that's what I was reading it. I was
just, that's what it reminded me of.
It reminded me of that's,
that's what
my predecessors in the seal teams in
Vietnam would do to the enemy and now the
enemy was doing it to us or to
you guys. It's really scary. Um,
this is, this is an interesting spot.
You're heading home for leave. From there,
I left in May and caught series of
connecting flights home to America.
I gave Kelsey a huge kiss at the airport
in Dallas and when I got back to the
house, gave our dog buddy a big
hug. It felt great to be back,
but it also felt surreal. And this is
the strange part of this leave time.
I didn't quite know
what to do with myself.
I could take a hot
shower anytime I wanted.
I could sit on the couch
and play video games.
I could drink a beer and eat a
cheeseburger outside on the back porch.
Nobody was shooting at me.
Nobody stunk.
Nobody was sleeping on triple stacked.
IDDS Kelsey was finishing up the
semester with college and work.
So I bought a truck and we drove
up to Michigan to see my parents.
We had a few bright and happy days
with them than it was soon time to go.
Just like that,
I hugged my parents,
gave Kelsey a big kiss and flew out
to Detroit to head back overseas.
It felt oddly good to
be back to Afghanistan.
The feeling is difficult
to explain in America.
When I'd hung around with some friends
in Dallas and got reacquainted with some
of my buddies from high
school back in Michigan,
I'd seen firsthand hand how
most of the people my age lived.
If a dude who's 22 or 23 like me,
he was usually finishing up college or
hanging out trying to find an internship
or an entry level job.
He might be living in his parents'
basement trying to scrape together enough
money to move out,
or maybe he was partying hard on
weekends or maybe still in a frat.
He was almost always short on money.
Almost always wondering
what to do with his future.
Not that there was anything wrong with
any of that guy's got to do what a guy's
got to do. But by contrast,
at my age in the military,
I lead people in combat.
I controlled firefights.
I handled hundreds of thousands
of dollars worth of equipment.
I made decisions that affected whether
people would live or die. It felt real.
On a personal level. I made decent money.
I was married, I had a good credit score.
I was thinking of buying a house soon.
It felt good to be trusted
with this much responsibility.
I was proud of my drive and sense of
accomplishment. I was already a man.
I think statements like that are
like what? Get kids or if I say kids,
but like when I meet kids, like
I've just met at, at this uh,
event we were just at in this,
you know, he's like, Hey,
I'm 19 I just joined the Marine Corps.
I'm leaving September 18th and that
statements like that is what I think makes
people do in the middle of,
it gets a lot of people that joined the
military like 22 years old. Oh yeah,
you're getting paid.
You've got a steady job.
Your job is more meaningful than any
job they could have. I mean, nevermind,
maybe they're working in fast
food, right? Like I did. You don't,
never mind that they're working Wendy's.
Even
if they have a kick ass job somewhere,
it doesn't matter.
Your job is more meaningful because you're
a soldier fighting for freedom. Yeah.
And they would,
you know,
you'd go back home and you see what
they're doing and you're like, wow,
my life to change. You know? And I'm
like, I'm going to Afghanistan. Uh,
I got married, I have an apartment. I'd,
you know, I'd have two cars or whatever.
And it's at that young of an age, I
mean, and my friends back home, they,
they were still a really nice,
and you know,
I still get along with
them and everything.
I just felt like what I was doing
was, was a different purpose. And,
and I was trusted with more things.
I mean,
when you're in college and everybody's
like, Oh, you're a kid in college,
but when you're in the army and
you're like, oh, you're in the army,
you're on your second deployment,
you know,
what do you do it while I'm in charge
of seven other lives is included as well
as my own. And I tell them
where to move, what to do,
how to shoot and how to do things.
And they're like, oh, okay, yeah,
I'll get some kid in the gym. They might
jam, will be like, oh yeah, well you know,
well I'm only 23 and I'll,
oh yeah,
when I was at 23,000 my
third seal platoon killed.
Actually we weren't, we were drinking
beers because there was nothing going on.
But anyway, still in Budweiser
killing Budweiser, like a beast. Um,
so then how did you feel about that
two weeks of leave during the middle of
deployment? Well, I mean, it's a constant
worry. Like, how am my guys doing?
We all had a satellite phone, we didn't
have internet or things like that,
so I couldn't just be like, hit him up
real quick. On a, because the army is,
makes you do that well, yeah, yeah.
They, they allow it and then they,
they say you need, you know this
stuff. But they're pretty, aren't they?
Don't they push it
pretty hard? No, I mean,
well that's uh, and I, and I don't
just, uh, I don't discriminate.
I don't know how to say this
politically correct. There's,
there's the army that's at Bagram air
force base that wears PT belts that,
you know,
goes to Dunkin,
goes and gets her Dunkin donuts and that
complaints because not a lot of taste
to hot. And then there's the
people like us where it's like,
there's 22 of us are 21 of us sitting out
in middle of nowhere taking no showers.
No one's going to come say,
hey, you need to do this.
We had one kid come out and I
ran into him again and Lansing,
Michigan actually had an event,
you know, out of the military.
And I didn't realize it was him, but he
came out, he chose to be a financial, um,
guy, unless it is in the financial
world and that's fine. Hey,
you want to do finance or you want work
on the s four shop great comes out.
They're given a survey,
some dumb survey that they're
just whatever big army wants,
you know the good idea,
fairies or whatever.
But he's on the rooftop and he's like,
Oh man, I hope we get in a gun fight.
It's going to be great and look over and
say excuse me. And he's like, well no,
I just, you know, cause I, I'm on the
five all the time. I just, I love,
I want to see a gun, you know, I
hope we get in a firefight. I said,
w what don't you get if they shoot at us,
my guys could get hit for
what you're hoping happens
here. I said, I got an idea,
get off my roof. And he's like,
well, I said, no, seriously get,
I'm going to throw you off this roof.
You don't get off it.
And he looked at a critter. When am
I when a guys and criticals, oh no,
sergeant mills is real. He'll throw
you off this room. And I said,
if we get shot at,
don't get my guys, wait,
stay the fuck off the roof and get down.
And he was just like, but I don't get it.
I'm like, it's not a game.
This isn't, I mean, when we
get in a firefight, you know,
we get,
you know,
people run up on their PT shorts and their
flip flops and they got the Kevlar on
their body armor.
But I mean that's real.
I bullets are flying and the
way he was just so nonchalant.
I hope we get a firefight.
That'd be really cool.
It's like my guys could get shot. Like
what, what part of cool don't you get?
So I mean the, the, you know,
the army does push something to,
but other times were just left alone.
Yeah. I just remember guys going from La,
from guys that were in combat
all the time, not fobbing but,
and they did seem like the command,
their commands wanted him to go home
for those two weeks and hey man,
you need to take this break on
the leaves. Mandatory. Yeah.
I thought you meant like calling home,
calling home stuff's not man.
[inaudible] going home. Sorry. Yeah, yeah.
You have to go home. You have to go. Okay.
That's what I thought in a lot of guys.
Some guys don't want to, but you have to,
you know the call home
thing I think is is,
I don't know how often you called home,
but I tried to call him like once a week.
Once or twice a week.
Because if you start doing more than that,
I think it's worse on both before you run
out of things to say, oh, that's cool.
What's going, you know, for,
I mean, no offense to anybody
who loved life out there,
but in my wife and I get along great, you
know? But when I would call home, hey,
were you doing well? I just know today
in Afghanistan, I don't want to be like,
well,
I was out now I got shot at,
and then I ended up killing two people
and then this guy got hurt. But it's,
it's okay, he's going to be fine.
Don't worry about dates, you know?
She can't say that Kinda stuff like, oh
well, you know, I went on patrol today,
got to help with help a kid tie his
shoe, you know, and like that gets old.
And then what'd you do?
Well,
I went to school today and I mean
there's no real story there, right?
So you got to let it build for
a week or two. You know, I,
I definitely recommend that. I mean
that in the nicest way. I know. Totally.
And I think if you're, if you're calling
home every day, then you're like,
you're missing it. You're
connecting and just like, no,
like you said, let it build,
have something to talk about Rio and
cause then it gets annoying. Like, well,
what are you thinking about? And then
you get, you know, I see it happen. I,
you know, I even say I, it happened
to me and Kelsey, um, you know, like,
what are you thinking about?
Whoa. No. Are you thinking,
what do you want to talk
about? Well, I don't know. Oh,
you got nothing to talk to me
about. It's like, well, no, I don't.
And it's not a bad thing. It's not that
I love you any less, it's that literally,
I can't tell you what happened here
because it's not going to make you feel
better about the situation.
So you know,
another thing is,
you know,
you got all this stuff going
on and the new website,
you won't believe this and you're
like, what? And she's like, um,
we lost that library book that we got
out and now they called and they want us
to pay for it. And you're like, it just
got the check was getting the check.
We're going to be good. Are they
overcharging? I mean, do your research,
you find it online cheaper.
Yeah.
Yeah. Some of the big, the big, yeah,
the big trauma drama at home, you know,
they're wide eyed. Like,
oh no. It's like, okay,
well I watched the guy bleeding nose
bleed out today and put my finger on a
bullet holes, so I get what you're saying.
The same thing. I was like, Whoa, my God,
can you believe this? But you go ahead.
Tell me about what happened with you.
Tell you, tell me about the spoiled by
mandates that you had on your sandwich.
MMM. Oh, that's no joke.
That's awful. You get home
from that deployment. Going back to the
book, my parents flew down from Michigan,
Josh and Deanna, this is your,
Josh is your brother-in-law. DNS.
His wife were there and some of
the guys from my unit came over.
I manned the barbecue smell of charcoal,
fired hamburgers,
drifted over the neighborhood,
and I felt like the luckiest man alive.
Kelsey and I had a dog,
two cars and now a house.
We were young family
living the American dream.
So you had the goal of Vine House and
now you actually bought one, right?
Power of attorney. I called my wife
and she's like, guess what I did today?
I was like, what? She goes,
I bought a house. I'm like,
how'd you do that? She's like,
well, you bought it on that piece of
paper. I'm attorney. So speaking of jokes,
I tell every time I talk
get there. But uh, no.
We bought a house and then my brother
in law, he was, they had a young,
a young child. They still do Reagan,
but at the time she was like seven,
eight months old I guess.
And it's like you drink at night Josh,
because I have responsibility,
you know, like, oh I'm,
I'm all holier than thou or
something like I can't drink.
And then by the end of the
night he passed out in the fire.
Junk is can be smoked a pack, a snack.
He doesn't even smoke cigarettes,
smoke cigarettes,
trying to wake him up.
He's in a fire ant here on my
backyard like, oh, that hurts so bad.
And then I was like responsibilities,
famous last words
back to them
book.
Fortunately after I got home,
I didn't struggle with any past
memories of combat. Although I do,
I know any number of soldiers who do.
I told a few stories to
Kelsey about our units,
time and row and BMG about going without
a shower for so long and about some
firefights.
We got into an impala and corvette,
but she didn't like to talk about those
things much and I understood that.
I found I could shut off
the memory's pretty easily.
My logic was straightforward. I was
a combat soldier. That's what I did.
I told my mind to go to certain places
and I refuse to allow it to go to other
places. I found that I could connect
with my family best that way.
Although I know other guys handled
things differently with equal success.
And the reason I threw that in there,
it's just cause you know,
I get a lot of guys that
asked me about how to handle
the, the whatever memories
that are bringing it home.
And I thought that was a pretty
good methodology man. Like, okay,
I'm not going to think about
that right now. Yeah. I mean I,
it wasn't like I had a barrier. Um, you,
you're just so desensitized when
you're over there. Like, um,
I'm pretty sure the book talks about it,
but we went out on patrol and then when
the a and a guys or amp was wearing a
bright green, you know, uh,
like a construction vest and now we're
all in the getting ready to load up in
the trucks. And someone made the joke,
I think it was me or maybe creator,
but either way, we're like, well
that guy's going to get shot today.
Cause he stood out,
ended up being the only guy that was
shot that day and he ended up dying,
you know, eventually from his wounds.
But she's like, oh well he got he. Yup,
that guy died. But you're just, you
don't say it like hoping to get shot,
but you're just like, whoa. That's
part of what happens. But, uh,
she didn't like hearing my stories
of the combat and things like that.
So I was just like, well, I guess
I won't talk about him. She's like,
you just get so excited about telling
those stories and you laugh about it and
it's real serious. I'm like, well,
I made it like, you know, well,
you still snap in action.
I was driving in my house with my buddy
and we went past the firing range and
they opened up the two forties and like
I hit the brakes, contact, right contact,
right. And I pull over and me and
him are both reaching for our,
our m four is we're supposed to be next to
us. We're like, oh Yo, I made a minivan.
It was a Chevy impala for
me. It wasn't anywhere.
That's beautiful. I haven't been even,
I love it. Oh, speaking of minivans,
you found out you're, you're, uh,
going to be a daddy at this point to
when you came home from your second
deployment. Oh no, that'd be awful.
If I came second appointment,
if I was gonna be a day, it
took us a little while. Oh Wow.
Four months after I got back to find
out we're gonna. Yeah. Right on. Yeah.
I guess confused. I wasn't home. I wasn't,
I wasn't trying to imply anything. Yeah.
But we, uh, yeah, so, uh, I
didn't plan on it right away.
Um, you know, having children,
but found out we were going to have
children or have a daughter and worked out
great. You know, I'm very excited.
Did the whole nesting thing.
My wife had a sweet Mazda three hatchback
would love testing thing. You know,
like you said the baby room
up, get everything. Oh yeah.
I could tell my wife because I bought
her a brand new car in 2010 it was brand
new off the line Mazda three hatchback.
She loves it. I loved it. And I was like,
that baby, she's not gonna fit in
that car. And she was like, yeah,
it's going to be fine. I'm like, no,
it's not. Finally I got so mad one day,
like after arguing with her about it,
I went up there and I popped
the car seat in and say,
go ahead and jump into Jerry
driver's seat, honey, go ahead.
Jump in there and she couldn't fit in.
She's like, Oh, just get rid of it. Then.
She was so mad. I loved every second
of, you know, cause then I won.
I won that game. Right. You
were right. That feels good. Um,
I got you off topic. Sorry.
Yeah, we're going to have a kid.
I'm straight on topic of way tight on
topic over here. I know you're, yeah,
well you're a professional. I
didn't doubt that. Uh, September 27,
2011, our daughter was born. Wow.
I made some weird noises
in the back of my throat.
There are kid was with Goo all over her
and she was wrinkly and scrunched up and
all I could think of that. She was
the most beautiful thing in the world.
It's so great to cry.
The nurse said I didn't know how to cry
so I just kept making weird noises in my
throat is awkward. I was like, nurses
like it's okay, it's okay to cry,
Mr. Mills. I'm like
cry. And I'm like, whew.
That was weird in the side. He's
like, this guy's taking this kid home.
I mean almost fought the
pediatrician that day
they were talking about Belgium beer or
some damn thing and like I hear the two
doctors talking and my kids in there
crying and the nurse comes out say, hey,
who suppose to be looking at my kid?
And they're like, oh doctor this you,
he has a baby in there cause I don't
have one in there. And she goes,
you must have a guy goes,
huh? I almost forgot. Huh?
And chuckles it off and then
goes back talk. And I told her,
I said get that kid back in that room.
And I turned around and that guy,
and I'm already up like you know,
1820 hours cause we went into labor and
do so whatever and eyes are bloodshot
and I'm just like still jack from
lifting weights and I'm like, you know,
you're not going to look at my kid,
find a better pediatrician.
And the guy's like, and I had to go
get calcium element in the in. She was,
they were very nice when they,
I don't know,
I don't know why I'm
towering over this guy.
Like I will beat you if you touch my kid.
You're not doing your job bro.
Now let me put her in the car.
So you'd take her home and we get home
and my mother in law's with us and we're
looking at in Kelsey [inaudible] she was,
why she not buckled as a damn man.
I thought you did. She was trapped. I
thought you did it strike, you know,
direct on for my kid.
Good Dad award number one coming out of
the gates coming out of the gates strong.
I picked fail 45 minute drive, no car or
no buckled. Garcia. I'm a good driver,
so that's good. Luckily, uh, and meanwhile
this time you're still a soldier.
You go to,
you go to a jump master school and you
failed jump master school the first time
I did any, did the sad part, it wasn't
like the j Npi or you guys jump masters.
Did you fail the written exam?
That reading is fundamental.
What that academic um,
part of jump master school,
I've heard that's the most brutal part.
It was rough. It was rough. And uh,
I feel I failed that and everyone's like,
oh, you must be a dumb ass. I'm like,
I am. But I went back
the next week, you know,
the next cycle and I ended up through,
you know, I thought it was cool in here.
You talked about, um, you know, one
kid you threw out the plane. Yeah,
yeah. I get another kid. You kicked
out of the plane. They were fine. Yeah.
And that's the thing, they
can't win. Thank you later.
Cause they're just like scared. Right?
I'm not sure if they made it on,
I don't know really well in the
whole book that you made up here.
Yeah. And claimed most
fabricated look. Uh No. Yeah.
So I give them a brief and I they always
made the youngest or the like the least
senior guy give the brief.
And so like you tell him the brief,
if you know I say green light go and
you don't go give you the orchard more
times. If you don't jump out we'll unhook
you, attach you, give you all four.
And I'll such equipment though,
you know,
say go to the real
paratroopers or whatever.
It's what I know jumper is that when
it's called a name for it. Yeah.
A jump refusal jump refusal.
That's right.
So yeah cause then that military term pro.
Oh yeah. And then as I'd say my brief,
your, this is all three
pages you got to memorize.
That stopped my brief right there and say,
but I guarantee you today if you're on
my door you are going. So I told the guy,
you know,
green light go.
And like the first guy went the
second I went there and guy went,
fourth guy or whatever,
then I'll go and then finally I get to
like 13 or 14 I supposed to exit all,
you know, 30 paratroopers are 32,
whatever. Uh, and this guy's like froze.
And I'm like,
I know you think you're not going to
go but you better jump off this plane.
And he was like, you know, and I
said, I told you you were going.
And then back with shirt back was pants.
I just throw them out.
And then the person behind was like,
I'm like getting going there.
And then another jump, the
same thing happened. I said,
I told you you were going,
he's, they're frozen the door like in one
foot back. And I just grab the top of,
oh, sorry. I backed up,
grab the top of the plane.
I just kicked right in the back of
his parachute out the door. He went,
I was like, we'd hear those rumors,
but I never saw it happen. I mean,
if they don't jump,
they're going to lose money and then
they're going to waste a good pass and end
up playing.
Either can go back around,
make another pass and like prolong
everybody's night and make it harder.
Because I haven't personally
gotta do paperwork on now,
which I don't like to do.
Or you can barely write.
Yeah. What I understand.
So why no right hand so please be right
handed. So we expect, but that's cool.
Take tape folks to me with
like, um, but, but yeah,
I mean I saw it was just fear got the
best of them and I just was like, no,
we're going today. And you're, you know,
I said some other choice words
in their ear, but they went.
But what I liked about that from like a
broader perspective than just airborne
school is like so often, man, people just
need to like go. Cause like you said,
once you go and you get that
first thing under your belt,
then can they go and they jump.
It's no problem. You know,
but so often people or
did they just hesitate,
they're just scared of the unknown. You
know, and what you gotta do is just go,
just jump. Well, my fit
jumping airborne school back,
I was, you know, Pv two mills,
I jumped out and it was nighttime
combat was so scared. I know what to do,
but I was like, I'm not going to be the
big sissy on this airplane, you know.
So I dove out like Superman and I got
my left leg caught up in the risers.
I was coming down like a,
like a flamingo and my shoot started
collapse on me and I was shaking my,
I was falling fastener,
but I pull my reserve. You,
you pulled your reserve and everyone cool.
Yeah, no kid. They were mad about that.
Oh yeah. But I was dropping fast and I
guess you survived, which is a good thing.
Yeah. Yeah. But my leg
was tangled up so bad.
Send the first jump in
division and I'm like, oh,
I don't know if I want to do this anymore.
And then the guy in front of me went
and I was like, well, okay. He did it.
That's, yeah, that's not
good to have, uh, uh,
have to pull your reserve and
airborne school. Um, but I mean,
it wasn't because of a malfunction.
It's cause my own stupidity.
I dove out like you see
with me on my left leg,
got caught up in there and
I couldn't shake it out.
And then I was hit like watching
the silhouettes above me,
like boilers are of
males. I'm like, okay, um,
you pick up,
he's six,
so now you're now you're staff
sergeant take over a weapons squad,
which is a senior spot. But I was, I went
to work that day on the, I got picked,
finished all ALC or whatever.
Um, and which is e six course.
I went to my first started,
said I have offers and you know,
second first brigade a five away and I'm,
I'm going to take those.
I don't have a squad leader spot.
You know,
when I get back from this four
day vacation or four day break,
I came back and gave me the senior
spot. Here. He goes, Oh yes.
Uh, and Kelsey, she didn't really want
you to go overseas again. Did she?
I mean, yes and no. She understood it,
but I mean obviously no wife wants to,
their loved one to go overseas
or their husbands go overseas,
but we just bought a house. The
baby was just born. Quite frankly,
we could have used,
we could use the tax free money 100% could
use the money that you get from being
over there and also we have the soldiers
come to my house and have barbecues and
she sees how they look up to me and
how I'm in charge of them and it's this
whole comradery and brotherhood thing.
I had orders to Fort Hood.
I had my sergeant major
cancel them. I was like, ah,
I don't know why you're kicking me out.
He goes, I'm not kicking you out. I said,
sergeant major, I have orders to Fort
Hood and he's like, do you not want to go?
I said, no, I need you to play
with these guys. So he's just like,
I'll take care of.
Yeah.
The way you put it in the book is,
the reason I went overseas was
because of the soldier next to me.
The guys in my squad, our job was to
protect American, keep the Taliban at bay.
I drained my men, I taught them all. I
knew it was my job to take care of them.
I couldn't imagine them
deploying without me.
Yeah. I mean I was quite frankly
upset when I got those orders. Um,
but they were building a new brigade and
they want to combat ncls with over two
years of combat experience to go
help, you know, lead these guys.
And I was like a noble, I get it,
but not, not for me right now.
Okay.
You leaving? Um, and Josh is
going away at the same time.
Your brother in law,
your wife's brother going away.
Same time here we go back to the book.
She was in tears,
a beautiful mess. Josh was leaving
on that same deployment too,
but a day later than I was. So he came
to see me off and support his sister.
I hugged him and he hugged me back.
Chloe was five months old and
sleeping soundly in her car seat.
She never woke up. When I
kissed her cheek, I on strap.
My daughter picked her up and cradled
are tightly. One last time in my arms,
she inhaled,
deeply smiled and carried on sleeping.
Then I waved goodbye walking
away from my loved ones.
I had to ask myself if
this third deployment felt
different from the first two I
had a child to think about now a family.
I knew there would be 10
stays in firefights ahead,
but honestly I wasn't afraid of dying.
Yeah,
I wouldn't be reckless and make myself
an easy target and I didn't want to die,
but I knew that if I got hit,
then I got hit.
If it happened that it was meant to be
as a soldier,
it's not like I talk about my emotions
every day. I don't write poetry.
I don't watch romantic comedies. As
a rule, I'm trained to kill people.
That's what I do.
You've got to be tough in the 82nd
you've got to be as hard as life.
You don't want to show weakness ever,
particularly with any of your guys around.
When you're overseas and out in the middle
of nowhere and you have 12 to 20 guys
with you, you can't take a seat
and say you're done. As a leader,
I couldn't throw my helmet down and
complain that things weren't fair.
You have to make the best of it.
You'd have to keep going.
You've got to be as tough as they come.
But even so,
as I walked away from my wife
and child and brother-in-law,
the wind struck my eye and I wiped away
the wetness with the back of my sleeve.
Okay.
Harder going away on this deployment?
No, a little bit. Yeah. It didn't feel
right. Um, I actually had a conversation,
my brother in law and in his garage
with him and I was like, you know, Josh,
it's always the guy that you don't
expect to get hit and it gets hit and uh,
we can start naming all the people
from our deployments cause we the same
brigade, always just different units
has it. I just don't feel good about it,
you know? I mean, not that I couldn't go
where I wasn't going to go, but, but yeah,
it was harder. You know,
my wife and everything,
I was supposed to leave the next day I
went to work and they're like, hey, look,
we need you to take this
chocolate guys over. Um,
can you leave tonight instead of tomorrow
night? And I was like, well, yeah,
but I got to leave work right now and
I gotta go see my wife and my kid.
And they're like, yeah, yeah, you can go.
So I went. Um, but it, it does, you know,
I wouldn't say each deployments harder.
Um,
the second one wasn't hard for me
to go. I mean, had said goodbye,
but part of my job, the
third one was more, man,
I hope I get to come back home. But you've
got to push those thoughts, you know,
out of your head. You can't
stop. You can't dwell on it.
You can't think about it.
You can't, you know, worry
about what's going to happen.
You got to just push through and whatever
happens does happen. But you know,
as long as you're not reckless
and careless, you know, you,
you can't affect what your
outcomes are going to be anyway.
So you might as well just keep
pushing forward. Yeah. Do you, um,
and now you end up on
this deployment the fall,
but a strong point that you're in so
small, it doesn't even have a name,
just like out in the middle of nowhere.
This is drunk.
And you got there. And what was the,
uh, what was the environment like there?
I mean, the, the units that leave
always give real great advice.
Um,
and their commander told our commander,
you're not gonna really change a
lot stuff here with how the rules of
engagements now,
um,
because the rules of engagements over
different presidencies are different.
Leadership changed. And they
said, you know, when we go out,
we take shape and cream, we line where
we walked, you know, we come back,
that's all you're gonna do. And of course,
when we get there were hard charging.
We're like, we're going to go here,
here, here, and here and here.
And Sop is changed. The bow space,
I'll changed. Uh, we lived in, um,
like my first boat,
I was on a big five second appointment,
I was in a row of little out, a
little strong points and fobs. Um,
and then this one we were
just like, hey, here you go.
We're going to helicopter
you and you're dropped off.
They says you ThreeSixty around is all
bad. And uh, that's just how it was.
So we'd go out the first day I went
out and got huge firefight. Um,
and that's when my guys really understood,
like I wasn't a lot of schools.
Like I went to college and went to
jump school and went to the advanced
leadership course, ALC course for aesics.
So when I got back and I got to, uh,
the weapons squad leader spot, some of
the guys didn't know who I was from.
Anybody. My first sergeant knew man,
that's why I got the spot. But, um,
the other guys were like, why the hell
is this guy jokes around? He doesn't,
he's not mean he doesn't smoke
anybody. He's, he's, you know, really,
I was polite I guess or whatever,
you know, normal everyday guy.
I didn't have this chip on my
shoulder after I first firefight,
like two of the guys that came from a
different industry unit where like, look,
I didn't get while you
were in the squad leader,
I didn't get how you got you six.
Um, and while you were in charge,
but now I do because you know
when shit hits the fan and I was,
I was a guy needed to be there I guess.
Yeah.
I mean this firefight going
to go into the book here. Uh,
Sergeant Butler yelled, I'm hit, I'm hit.
One of his team leaders,
Sergeant Marty Miller ran over to him
and swept his hands long Butler's body to
look for blood. Miller ran back to
our lieutenants are four we could,
he couldn't find any.
And you, you just, um,
you sprinted out into this river bed
during this fire fights going on and here
you are. I'm still wearing my body armor,
but I was essentially weapon lists.
If I'd kept my rifle,
it would only slowed me down.
I ran over to where Sergeant Butler lay,
he was probably 50 meters total away.
It's my leg. He shouted. I can't put
any weight on it. Shut up. I yelled,
get on my back. Now let's go
without waiting for him to answer.
I grabbed his right hand with my left,
squatted down and threw him over
my shoulders and a fireman's carry.
He was probably 185 pounds.
I have to come up and ran back to safety.
So there you go.
Just uh,
I understand after you perform like that
to firefight your boys like, oh yeah,
we get it. Well we uh, yeah, so we were
on one side of the Wadi, the
driver bed and uh, my CEO was like,
we're going to cross this river bed. And
I'm like, all right. I mean that's really,
really open but let's do it. So
first, second and headquarters,
whatever went across.
Right, exactly. And just, just,
I always have to point this stuff out
cause we have a lot of guys that are in
the military that listen to this and so
you're just doing a classic cover move.
One element is going to stay back on the
high ground or on one side of the river
to cover as the other other
elements pushing across.
Yeah.
And this was our first day in country.
So we're just trying to
learn the battlespace. Okay.
Cause we were thinking about setting up
another uh, oop or strong point on the,
on the Wadi,
cause there's a lot of traffic and um,
they start to move over over there
and they'd get about 50 meters away,
75 meters, whatever. And then all hell
breaks loose shots from everywhere.
And third squad and four squad weapons
squad was just me are over on the river,
you know,
riverbed and we start laying in,
everybody ducks down takes cover and I'm
still standing and I'm yelling at them.
One of my guns shooting to the far left.
Where should we shoot into the far right,
use the right elements.
So I walk over and I kicked
the team leader, you know,
actually I think it might,
it's Max's head real hard. And I said,
I said, you fix this and fix it now.
And I told him where to shoot.
And went back over and a
direct to some more traffic.
And then some of the other two team
leaders from the third squad were just
firing all their rounds after
we already gained the fire.
Superiorities I yelled at them and said,
you to know better,
you've been here before,
control your rounds,
control your flyer and just
make sure it's a pressing.
And then Butler went down and were
like, oh, Butler just got hit.
And he ended up tearing his MCL ACL
and a meniscus or whatever. I mean,
this is pretty bad damage. And um,
my first starts like third squad,
go and get him and I, I said,
no first our nor, but I got it.
So I took my weapon off am I am
for, you know, and I was like, here,
hold this for me. I tossed in my m
four, because there's just, you know,
it gets in the way and I
ran down. Then the ane, hey,
we're on the riverbank, right?
Kind of right behind where they're at.
I said, you guys do not shoot that,
don't you? I can shoot, you
know, don't you shoot me in
the back? Sorry about that.
I ain't gotta edit that or
maybe you don't. I was like,
don't you guys shoot me?
I ran out and got him, took him back
and I set him down. So I ran a out 50,
came back and took them about
about 50 to 80 behind the building,
set them down and I sat down and
get a drink of water at first sight.
Like my first son goes to sergeant males
need you back here. Oh, okay. I ran back.
I was like, Oh crap. Where's my gun? And
Marty had it somewhere. He's like, Oh,
here you go.
And I was the last one on the objective.
We had to hike back two miles
with Butler on a stretcher. Um,
but that was the last one with
the fo on the objective, uh,
and smoke for the Kyle was to come
over and cover our movement to them.
The two guys at yelled at,
or the ones that told me,
they found me a hell and back like,
we get it now sergeant mills
will find you're held back.
They were just kept shooting them like,
you guys are team leaders,
you've been here.
What are you doing?
Yeah, that's awesome man. Just reality
check. It's, it's a, it's another example.
I mean again, just you're talking about
how you were in leadership position.
You're just backed off a little bit.
You're,
you're paying attention
to what's going on.
Instead of you being on
your gun and shooting, your
backed off, you're watching.
That's what you need to do
in a leadership position.
You got to back off a little bit.
You got to observe what's happening.
You got to make sense of what's happening
and then you've got to make sure that
people are doing the right things.
Yeah, I mean, you know, I, if I
shot my gun, I mean that's great.
I got chance changed,
shoot my m four and do had to do,
but if I wasn't controlling my
too heavy weapons squad, you know,
like I had the two forties I was
king of the battlefield, if you will,
and with the heaviest fire pilot,
I was in charge of it.
They weren't doing the job the right way.
Then we were all in trouble.
Yeah. As I always say, God
bless the machine gunners. Um,
yeah.
Any of that.
It sounds like that deployment was,
I mean the,
the firefights that you talk
about in here, we're a lot,
you're getting a lot of firefights every
other day, if not every day. And so,
so this one here, you went
out and did this raid, um,
and then you get word after you do this
raid that there's no aircraft to come
and pick you up from the raid
and go ahead and walk back.
Yeah, that's good times. Yeah.
We, uh, we went out, we, um,
I told my guys like, look, it's
going to be hellacious. Bring extra.
We had each of us 2000 rounds of seven,
six to gain. And then we also had,
um, I always carried 2000
rounds of seven, six,
two or I guess depending on the mission,
it would change me a thousand to 2000.
And then I carry 20 grenades,
10 on my, on my, uh,
armor and 10 in my bag. And then another
20, 40 Mike, Mike and I have two or three.
Jesus. And then 420, um,
five, five, six rounds,
like not in my magazines. And I always
had programs like freaking 200 pounds.
Yeah. What? Yeah, but without, without
ammunition you're kind of screwed.
That's true. Good point. So I was at 12
magazines on my person and then I'd have,
you know, 13th 1:00 AM I in the chamber.
So I had 13 full magazines on me,
not because 13 is like
some special number,
just cause like my mag pouches where yeah,
my mag pouch was, you know, too deep.
So I could have six, three
on each side. Um, yeah.
And we went out there and we ended up
getting like seven different firefights in
my back home we had for, and uh, I got,
I got,
um,
I got put next to the gun the one time
and you know how it's called pig town rat.
Tell the cop when you put
your seven, six, two Lincoln,
you have one side come out and then you
switched back it in and then they'll try
to come out. So when you hooked
to a gun, it pulls out your bag.
And then if you have another bag
next to you, clip it together. Oh,
we shot through all my rounds.
One the,
one of the things which I do all the
seven, six, two rounds. I was like, oh,
this is so much on like lighter. And I
got to another spot in one of my guys,
Brandon, um, fast that he was one of
the guys got hurt with me later on,
but he was almost knocked at like
past now. So have you. I said,
I'm going to take my bag. He goes, no,
I go, sorry. I said, gimme your bag.
Don't argue with me. And I was like,
you need to make it back to the fob.
And then our, uh, our pa the, that
came out with this awesome guy,
ranger regiment guy and it
turned into be a doctor.
He was dehydrating really bad on the
lock back going hallucinations and stuff.
So, um, w we decided,
me and two other guys,
three other guys,
go ahead and just like try to head
and walk faster than everybody else.
I'm like made it back to the fob first
to get a get a m m wrap to come get them.
But yeah, and we actually, one of
the guys who were detained, we, we,
we detained all these guys that had 600
pounds, homemade explosives, batteries,
RPGs. And the thing was a
drone filed their RPG team
back on a motorcycle to this
compound, AK 47. But we didn't
get pictures with all their stuff.
So we turned them over to the local
national government and they said,
well you didn't get pictures of
these guys or these guys are free.
So they let them go. Turns
out the guy that uh, um,
we had detained one of
them cause we hide them.
Fingerprints were all
over my bomb and the,
there's 13 bombs in a row and they're
all over the bombs at the one that I hit.
So the guy that we captured as
the one that put the bomb in
Alpha troop caught him
and he took care of them.
So,
all right, sorry to bring
it down to tone. My Bet.
Going to April 10th,
2012 you get some Intel on the afternoon
that there's a IED out in the village
and you guys are going to go check
it out and here we go into the book.
We hiked only about 400 yards to the
village in addition to my weapons team.
There were other squads along on patrol,
a total of 28 soldiers.
My Lieutenant Zachary Louis went to the
left with the first and second squads
heading to meet with the village elders
while the rest of our men went with me
around the village to the outside to
offer support in case of an attack along
with my gun team I had in my platoon
sergeant and a medic Sergeant Daniel
Bateson with my group all looks calm.
It was just another day in Afghanistan,
another normal patrol.
We approached and abandoned ANA security
posts to portable buildings and stop
near the buildings to
establish a security perimeter.
I called for fessy to bring the sweeper
check.
This area was the only order I gave fast.
He walked up a path used by villagers
and scanned all the area around.
He went up and back and all was clear,
no beeps.
There was no reason to
question anything fast.
He finished his mind sweeping duties and
went up and went to set up on the far
flag.
I called riot up to to me and asked him
where he thought we should put the gun.
I knew where it should go,
but I wanted to let him decide,
making sure he knew his stuff.
He motioned to exactly where I thought we
should put it, a good spot, and I said,
all right, go get NAF and bring
them up here. That was it.
Riot let left to go get Nafta and
as he did, I set my backpack down.
The backpack, touching the dirt was
all. It took such a simple act of war.
My world erupted.
I saw a flash of flame and hurt,
hurt a huge Kaboom, hot, jagged
piece, pieces of explosives.
Rip through me.
I cartwheeled backward end over end,
hit the ground and slammed my face
hard against the compacted earth.
Instantly I felt my left
eye starting to swell shut.
I smelled burning flesh my own.
I tasted dirt and I was wet
with sweat and moisture,
just like I'd walked out of a hot shower.
Yeah,
dirt fell everywhere through the air.
It rained down and clung to my eyes,
nose and mouth.
I don't remember rolling over,
but I must have because I glanced to
the side and saw that my right arm was
completely gone.
I caught a glimpse of my left arm
covered in blood and tattered by arm.
Tremble does,
if it had a will of its own.
I looked down and saw my
right leg was also gone.
The stump looked like a piece of raw meat.
The bottom of my left
leg was still attached,
but held on only by a few strands of skin.
I saw all this in a flash.
In an instant.
Yeah,
I felt confusion, but no panic. My
first thought of what was of my guys,
I flopped my remaining
arm toward the microphone,
clipped to my carrier plate and somehow
managed to push the button. I hit a bomb.
I said, I need help. Bateson.
My medic rushed up to me along with
staff sergeant Keith Handbright,
our platoon sergeant, only about 30
seconds had passed since the blast.
Immediately they applied tourniquets to
hold whatever blood was still inside me.
I'm not gonna make it. I said, leave
me and go to save my guys. Shut up.
Sergeant Mills said,
Bateson let me do my job.
I ignored Bateson and yelled my man's
name like roll call fasc riot nef to see
if they were okay to were hit fastly
and riot and other medics were already
caring for them. They were
bleeding, but nothing was missing.
They yelled back that they were
going to be okay. I calmed down.
More soldiers ran toward me.
Sergeant Alex Voice and
other medic wondered aloud
where to best get ivy access.
There are no pulses to check
except for my carotid order artery.
He quickly ripped open my vest,
shaved a spot on my chest and put
an IV straight into my sternum.
It hurts going in and I must've howled
because he yelled at me that I was going
to be fine. I yelled back, doc, shut up.
I know he and I both calmed down.
Someone's stuck offense
in all pop in my mouth.
It's a potent pain killer that releases
as the pop dissolves I down the first
one, spit out the stick and asked for
another. You won't need it. Someone said,
I was still thinking that I was going
to die. I didn't want to show fear.
I didn't want to freak out. You never
want to show for your around your men.
Let me let my family know I dealt
with it without crying. I said,
tell him yourself someone
grunted he was being encouraging,
letting me know I wasn't dead yet.
I tried to see around me.
I raised my head wanting to
get a visual of FASC in riot.
Someone's shoved my head back
down by still commanded a voice.
My one eye was swollen,
completely shut.
The other eye was blurry from dirt. I
tried to raise my head again. Again,
I was pushed flat.
My eyes were watering.
Now the dirt turning to mud time passed
and I didn't know what was happening.
I mumbled something,
but there was no reply.
Only this steady wa or warp of a Black
Hawk helicopter touching down nearby.
Six men surrounded me,
have teed me up and carried me over.
All told,
it might've been 10 minutes since the
blast until the helicopter arrived.
Fessy in riot were first
inside the helicopter.
Everything was foggy and noisy and I
couldn't make out my surroundings clearly.
My two guys were on seats and I saw
blood and bandages jumbled in their
direction. FASC had shrapnel
in his face ride, had shrapnel,
his face, legs and hands.
Their images faded away.
Yeah.
I focused on the noise of the rotors.
We were in the air and the flight medic.
We're taking care of me
right at yelled in pain. I tried to look
around. Someone needed to attend to riot.
Where are the medics? One of the medics
were talking to the pilots upfront.
Riot was yelling again. I looked in fessy
direction and told them to calm down.
Fessy nodded.
Riot stopped yelling and I winked at him
to let him know he was going to be okay.
Yeah,
it was all I could think to do.
The flight medic.
Was it back in view? I could barely
see him. The goop in my eyes.
You are a green flight suit and
had a big Darth Vader helmet.
I tried to speak. He gave me a quizzical
look. I yelled as loud as I could.
Take your helmet off.
He took his helmet off.
Get my guys water and tell them they're
going to be okay. I barked, don't worry.
I'll take care of them for you.
He said he was busy with some
task on me that I couldn't see.
A moment went by and I added,
I'm sorry for what the medic asked for,
making you take your helmet off.
He gave me a ride grin.
I realized he'd been doing his
job all, all along doing it. Well,
both the medics had. I just couldn't
see all that was happening around me.
My mind went in and out.
I was coherent but fuzzy and spots.
In 15 minutes,
the helicopter landed in
Kandahar hospital staffed,
rushed me straight to the operating table.
We're going to put you under.
Now came a voice from
above me. I'm fine. I said,
leave me alone. The mass came over
my face and I tried to push it away.
I remember asking one question,
am I ever going to see my baby girl again?
Cool.
Little intense. Yeah. Yeah. I, uh,
my is more choice words. I didn't put
in the book, I said to the flight medic,
I had yelled three times and then
last time through the f word in there,
take your effing helmet
off. And he did, uh,
in my head I was just
thinking saving private Ryan,
don't go out like for your mom, like
the medic when he got shot in the movie.
And uh, I just, you know,
I was the guy that I had a sniper round
crack next to my head and I rolled in
and I was so embarrassed to
have rolled away from it. Um,
then I stood on top of the mountain in
Shawn off a magazine and a half before I
got back down. And, uh, so
just the whole don't show fear.
I figured I can't change what happened
right now. If I raise my policy,
I'm going to bleed faster. And,
um, you know, thanks to my platoon,
sergeant, uh, Sergeant Hambright and
Doc Bates and then doc voice, uh,
I was able to maintain most of my blood.
They must've slapped those things
on you. Quick tourniquets. Oh,
within 20 seconds or 30 seconds I think.
And how did was that,
was the aircraft airborne somewhere
and got redirected to you?
How'd you guys get a
helicopter there so fast?
I don't know.
We usually only went out when it was when
there was helicopters on station, um,
because the threat was so, so real. Um,
not that we need to talk about this
and you guys edit it out. But, um,
at nighttime the Taliban had free
reign to do what they wanted.
We were told because of politics
or whatever, somebody said,
we can go at nighttime.
So we had the best nighttime capabilities,
but we couldn't go out. So on the
red camera, 30 feet in the air,
we would watch them on the screen and
watch them put bombs in at nighttime and
we couldn't shoot him, couldn't
shoot mortars at them and
couldn't get him. So, uh,
it kind of sucked because you'd watch
them put the bombs and then the next day
you're supposed to go
out and try to find him.
And that's why in 2012 they
wouldn't let you shoot them a,
they won't let us go out and get them.
They're like, no, I can't go at nighttime.
And we're like, but we can see
them. I mean, I don't want,
if you guys talk about it,
you know, it doesn't bother
me. I just reality, you know,
I don't like,
I want you don't get political so
you don't have to on this with me.
But just watching him put bombs and
knowing I had to go and try to find them.
And then the guy that I found, uh,
or we walk back through, you know,
seven different firefights and 10 clicks,
uh,
when they went out to do the surveillance
on the site, that got blown up at, uh,
I blown up. There was 13 in a row
right there. And if some reason the,
my super Brandon went up and down, not
once, but twice and nothing alarmed him.
So there was six daisy chain together,
call it squad killer.
So you had to be the front guy to hit
the first one and then everybody behind
them would get just taken out.
So in a way it was as probably
better that I got hit that day.
Then have somebody walk past and hit
it and then everyone behind him you're
taken out too. Um, yeah. So just,
just the politics of war I guess kind
of sucked because I would watch him put
bombs in,
couldn't shoot him.
The Chi was to come on station and the
guy shooting Nsa Han yards away with
dropped their weapons and walk away
and all of a sudden they were no longer
combatant until the Chi was, we're out
of fuel and we weren't going to run,
you know, a thousand meters
this way because if we did,
then the guys just take either a case
and take off. So, you know, the red tape.
But when I got blown up, I did rate
on my lt until, yeah, I got hit. Uh,
I don't know how bad it is.
And I told my ma get away from me and
he kept fighting me off and tell me to
somebody my job. Then the doctors worked
on me for 14 hours. I was told nine, uh,
nine doctors and seven nurses
and two nurses for nine hours,
pump air into my lungs, keep me alive,
like took turns pumping air. Um,
I was so low on blood,
they did over 30 transfusions and
they didn't have enough in stock.
They were like on the big speaker in
Kandahar saying a positive blood and
universal, we need it now.
And they were right from,
I had a lot of tests I had to do for like,
you know,
possible HIV or things like
that because it was just like,
just take it and put it right
in. Yep. Cool. All right,
thanks for your blood and we're
gonna put it right in them. Um,
they knocked me out medically,
you know, maybe unconscious. Um,
and they kept me like that for four days.
So
I just realized, you know, I always
said God bless them machine gunners,
but how about a little God
bless the doctors and nurses
for sure. Oh absolutely.
And the medics and the medics.
I would sound like
I go when I speak, I, uh, my
one side's about perspective
and I tell him, you know,
about the guys that have not made it
back home and I'm thankful to still be
around and living and I'm going to keep
living, you know, for them so that,
you know,
their sacrifice wasn't in vain because
what happened to me is nowhere near what
happened. My Buddy Francis
Gene Phillips, a fourth there,
Frankie great friend of
mine, he died, you know,
let behind a wife and a
four year old at the time.
So I'm thankful for the medical
advancements in Vietnam.
A lot of guys didn't come back like me.
And I get sometimes people are like, well,
we just didn't see people like you
who during the Vietnam War. It's just,
it's so sad this happened.
And I say, well, that's the
guys, they didn't come back.
Yeah. You know, so, so yeah.
I mean the doctors know how to tie things
in and my calf muscles around the end
of my left leg now I guess for padding
or something, I'm just nuts, you know.
But um,
that was on the 10th and then I
still had my left hand when they,
they got done working on me. My wrist
is blown up pretty bad by my finger,
my index, my middle of my thumb.
And then two days later in bog them,
they cut it off.
My brother in law flew in from his outpost
to Kandahar with me and escorted me
because did you guys have to feel
blue books out moving before deployed?
We call it the blue book. It's
like, if I die, bury me with this.
It's not a blue book, but we
do. We do do that. Yeah. Well
I don't know. It was, yeah,
like a little blue pants.
They'd call it the Blue Book and the army.
But it's like, if I die, you
know, I want my wedding ring,
I want picture of my wife and I, my kid,
or you know, I want this music to play.
Right. Basically. Plan your
funeral is kind of morbid,
but I guess it's all right.
Um, but he was a guy who was
supposed to escort my body back home.
So he came to where I was at and then
they shipped me to bother them on April
12th and I was 12. They took a look at
my hand, like, it's not gonna make it,
it's just necrotizing and you know,
limb length is a huge thing,
so they cut it off. Um, and then, so
they didn't tell him they're doing it.
So I worked, rolled into surgery and
I came back into my hand was gone. Um,
but I didn't know, cause I still,
you know, medic or sedated.
And then two days later they went for
the very first time on April 14th and I
woke up in the room, my brother in law,
he was wanting to tell me, but what I,
I don't know if I'd put it in the book.
I don't think I did April 14th,
actually my birthday. So my 25th birthday
I found out as was a quadruple amputee.
And it's funny because on my first
deployment when I didn't know about
amputations and things and Josh was just
a friend of mine, not my brother in law,
I was like, look, I'm very athletic.
I play a lot of sports. If I,
if I lose a leg or something,
just let me bleed out. Like,
I mean I was that naive at 19 years old.
Like if I lose a hand, just I don't,
I don't need to live, you know,
cause I didn't know any different.
We're now I have, I wake up, no arms
and legs and I'm like, oh, okay.
Well at least I made it,
I guess.
Um, meanwhile, back on the home
front, going into the book,
Kelsey received a call at 11:53 AM her
time while standing in her parents'
kitchen in Dallas, Texas. She
was making a tuna fish sandwich
and, and then it's the commander on the
phone and she describes, you know, he,
he tells her straight forward,
you know, the severe injury.
And this is what she wrote in her journal.
I could not wrap my head around the
pain my husband must be feeling.
I was all alone in the
house and my action subset,
my daughter to the point
where she was screaming,
I could do nothing to sooth
her. I couldn't pick her
up. I couldn't look at her.
My body felt like he was being torn into.
I wanted so badly to be able to talk to
Travis and let them know I love him and
that I think God,
that he was still alive.
Did it continues on.
Kelsey called my dad in Michigan,
but when she tried to tell him what
happened, little would come out.
My Dad knew something was wrong
and kept repeating. Is he alive?
Is he alive?
And then your dad said this until you
go through something like that yourself,
it's hard to describe the feeling.
There is no eating anymore.
You don't leave the house. There's a
lot of pacing around. You just wait.
Whenever the phone rang,
we jumped.
You look at the phone and you don't
know if you want to answer it or not.
So it wasn't, obviously,
it wasn't just you that got
hit, um, to, you know, your,
your family back home gets hit with the
shock of all this and all also in your
squad. [inaudible] yeah, there. Yeah.
Which is the coolest name ever,
right. Cause it's spells the riot.
I've mentioned him earlier.
Um, but yeah, he got wounded.
He was pretty bad.
I mean he was able to get up and walk
a couple days after he was, it was,
he was sore for quite a bit
and then,
and then fast he got hit as well.
He did. And luckily he had his
sunglasses on, um, because he,
his face was just blasted, but he still
has, his vision is doing great. Uh,
just got engaged. So, um, I mean like,
yeah, it's just a bad day. You know,
my dad, when he says you
don't eat and do that stuff,
he actually was in the hospital with me
and got diverticulitis real bad and he
almost died.
He was so dehydrated and had to go in
and like give him surgery and like get
handout for six months. You probably
would be mad if I told her about it.
But he had a class me back cause you
got so dehydrated, um, cause you cared.
You know, it was just so, so
worrisome for him, you know?
And then when I woke up,
I was kind of a Dick.
I didn't want to like my brother
and I was like, you got to call,
you know Kelsey and you got to call
your mom and dad. And I'm like,
I'm not talking to anybody. Can
as you know, you're angry or sad.
You're questioning does God
hate me and my bad person?
What did I do wrong in life to get
this? I mean I pay my taxes, you know,
I have a family,
why would this happen to me?
And then a little bit goes like Forrest
Gump where it's like lieutenant Dan like,
no, what, what, what the hell, you
know, why did I live through this? Um,
is this some kind of sick punishment
that for something I did wrong? And, um,
I mean you, you come to a
realization like, hey, you know what,
sometimes bad things happen
to good people. It is what
it is. You can't change it.
You might as well keep pushing forward
and it's nothing I did wrong in life.
It's just what was slated.
So,
you know, that's what happened. Yeah.
I thought it was interesting. Um,
uh, that one of the guys on the
Medevac Bird Lik Rhoda Rhoda,
a Facebook to Kelsey and was explaining,
you know,
what it was like and, and
uh, yeah, I mean here,
here's what he wrote.
My name is first sergeant weight,
the other medic, the other flight
medic was staff sergeant hockersmith.
You belong to a family of warriors.
Other wounded soldiers in
the aircraft were injured and screaming,
but your husband is warm, worried about,
more worried about then than himself.
He described it.
Then he describes how you were doing the
thing and tell him to take his helmet
off and, and uh, you know,
here coming back to the book,
his face was dirty and there was Dustin,
his eyes, but he never shed a tear.
I replay in my mind a moment when he
looked at other wounded soldier at another
wounded soldier and wink to
reinsure them that it would be okay.
My crew is still on duty
and his unit's area.
Now we go back to Kandahar on Monday,
but we won't go back the same way.
I'm an e eight, but this aesics is the
example for myself and others to emulate.
Okay.
I actually, yeah, I've had to get my,
I was strapped down so I had to get my
arm out because when I was yelling at him
I was like, Hey, take your hand
off. I said, take your helmet off.
And that finally I got my arm off
straight. How were you conscious man,
that's freaking crazy. Good genes I guess.
Uh, you know, but I put my arm out and I,
I said, take your, you know,
helmet f word helmet off.
And I put my hand over my head,
the emotion, like, you know,
as my arms drooping down or whatever,
but I just don't take your helmet off.
And then he did and I was like,
get my guys walked around me fine.
And then later I did apologize for
yelling at him. I was like, Hey,
sorry I yelled in this war. I, yeah.
You know, but you know, at that time,
I guess maybe it was easier for me to
like think about everything else going on
except for myself, you know? And I
just, I just figured it is what it is.
Whatever's gonna happen is gonna happen
and it doesn't do me any justice to
scream out or yell or, or
be afraid. I mean, Hey,
I can't change what's going on right now.
So just do the best I can to, you know,
help situation.
Yeah, man. And, and Josh
shows up like you, you know,
you just talked about this
and Josh just say, Hey,
I'm going to tell it to you straight.
[inaudible] cause you asked,
you said to Josh, Hey, am I paralyzed
and I'm going to the book here. No Man,
Josh said you're not paralyzed. You
don't need to lie to me. I whispered.
I can take it. I'm going to
tell you straight. Josh knew.
I'd want to know the truth.
You're not paralyzed,
but both your arms and legs are gone.
The date was April 14th,
2012 still the same day as
when I'd heard the news.
I was a quadruple amputee.
It was my 25th birthday.
Okay.
Damn.
You talk about the pain and I think
this is something that people don't get
myself included. Um, uh,
the pain was so bad. Part of the pain
was the thought of what I'd become.
I could hardly picture the new me yet.
The pain was more than emotional.
It was a physical pain. It coursed through
my body. I felt like I was on fire.
I tried to focus on my breathing and
take stock of why my pain was so bad.
Even with all the medications
flowing through me,
it still felt like I was in a
red hot vice. I could hardly it.
I knew Josh would never lie to me,
but my arms and legs still
felt like they were attached.
My hands felt like they were burning
like someone who was clamping them inside
of an industrial furnace.
But my hands weren't there.
The flames were eating away.
My ligaments, my nerves, my skin, my legs,
my phantom legs were clamped in
that same fire bolt's of agony,
surge from limbs that
weren't the register,
that weren't there and registered
to a brain that's still was.
The pain came and went, came
and went, came and went.
Josh started in his seat and leaned or
starting to seat and lean closer. Travis,
you need me to get the nurse,
nurse. I didn't say anything.
I was itchy and sweating bad.
He pressed a buzzer than then.
Went out and got a cool cloth
and laid it on my forehead.
The nurse came in and upped my morphine
just before I went under again.
Everything that I'd always drilled
into myself, rushed through my mind.
Never show fear. Never let your
guys see you in pain. Don't cry out.
Even when I'd been lying on the ground
right after the blast, I'd felt pain then,
but I hadn't showed it when that I was
shoved through my chaff that was chest.
I was painful, but I wasn't going to
complain. Then you don't let people down.
You just don't,
but this time the pain was so bad.
It was still so bad, even with more
pain killers in me now. So bad.
So bad,
so bad.
This time I want to do the unthinkable.
Two words. Rose then began
to vocalize within my throat,
Josh. I said, yeah,
what do you need buddy?
I swallowed and whispered to words.
I quit.
Yeah, not good. I uh, I
don't know what I mean.
Is this a lot of pain? I
guess. I don't know why.
Yeah.
You know, you sit there any question like,
am I going to be a burden on my family?
Right. Why? How, you know, my wife,
should she stay with me? I mean,
what do I have left to
offer? Um, my dollar.
Am I going to be a monster when I get
to see her finally and then it's like,
why did I live through this? Why did
you know, why not make it, not that I'm,
I guess angry. I lived or at the time,
oh, you know, when that was happening,
I wasn't so much angry. He's just more
of a question. Like, why, what, what's,
what's the purpose? Why not just let
me go out. My life gets, you know,
400,000 from the government and,
and then she can go remarry and have
somebody that's able bodied and,
and live a happy life. But, uh, you
know, a lot of questions or you know,
when you're sitting in the hotel room
or I'm in a hospital bed, you know,
in a hospital room and you just got
stare at the ceiling the whole time.
You just never know what would
think in the military. It's easy.
Everything laid out for you.
This is our mission.
This is our plan is what we're going
to do is how we're going to get it done
there.
It's just all unknown.
And that pain, like from missing
limbs, it sounds freaking,
oh yeah.
I mean it was, I guess spike
getting drove through my heel, uh,
fingernails getting just ripped off and
then see it and it was just, it was bad.
What causes that? Uh, well, I mean
a lot of it is phantom limb pain.
So your nerves try to find where
your hands and your feet are.
And if they can't find it, they try to
redirect and keep trying to find it.
So it's just one excruciating,
you know,
zap to another and then they, uh,
in, you're probably gonna talk,
they had like experimental, um, things,
they try it on me cause it was so bad.
And after the second one, they tried, um,
I was like, oh, I feel a little better.
And then the doctor like was all excited.
Then I was like, oh no, the pain's back.
And I went, you know, got all yelling
out in pain and stuff. And he just,
he actually cried.
He felt so bad because it was to the
point where they've got to find some cure
or I'm going to be so,
um, um, just in the agony.
Yeah. Agony. Or I'll be
so used to the medication,
um, that the doses are going to get to
the point where I'm just gonna Odi on him,
you know, because I'm going
to be so, so, uh, a customer,
I can't think of the word
right now. It's killing me. Uh,
like you're talking to me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
My tolerance would be so high that
I'm just going to end up Odeon. Damn.
Of course. I was kind of like, you know,
you're wondering where you
get your sense of humor.
You're telling your dad what happened
and you're like, I stepped on a mine,
went flying through the air. I did a
one 80. It was crazy. Well, Travis,
my dad said, the important question
is, did you look good doing it?
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I think I did.
Yeah. Um, and meanwhile, Kelsey,
she, she, you know, you've been voice in
some of these concerns like about, hey,
can I even be a good dad now can,
I'm not going to be a burden.
You're kind of telling Josh some of those
things and she told or he told Kelsey
and here we go back to the book.
My brother told me that Travis has nervous
to see me because he doesn't know how
I will react or if I will continue
to love him as my husband.
These worries seem so trivial
to me because I will love
him through sickness and
health until death do us part.
I did not use those words
lightly when we got married.
I will be biased side everyday
for the rest of our lives,
whether he likes it or not.
Yeah,
I know his natural reaction will be to
push me away because of embarrassment or
feelings of letting me down.
But I just wish I could constantly
reassure him that my love for him is
unwavering.
Yeah. Well I mean when I saw her, I told
her she should go. I said, you know, hey,
you should take what we have. The house
is yours, the cars are your cell mine,
you know,
whatever and do what you need to do.
And I'll financially fund whenever
I can, you know? And she was like,
that's not how this works.
I want the handicap parking.
You know what she said?
So I was like,
man,
you are,
there's like a level of luck
involved when you get married.
I don't care who you are.
Um, oh. You know, like do,
you could easily marry like Satan,
you know, and I know, I know you,
I know plenty of guys that have made some
really bad came and call bad decisions
because it's just like, oh, okay,
I understand if you have this great coding
thing and all that and your whatever
that you can make a good decision,
then that's great.
But like a lot of guys in the military,
you're young and you're like,
you know what,
we're getting married and there's
just like a flip of the coin and you,
you got a saint. I mean, I literally
did, I'm like 17 days in person,
you know what would be great.
We just went to Mexico and that was how
we were gonna get married and then we
just got married. Yeah, let's do that.
That'd be a great story for everybody.
Whether it works or not.
Then you scored for sure.
Uh,
she got lucky to have me too. Well, I
didn't really pick that up, but um, okay.
We'll go with it. Yeah. Moving on. Hey,
I wasn't when you've saw
Chloe for the first time,
so you need didn't get
back to Walter Reed?
I did, yeah. April
17th. I got back and um,
the first time I got to see Kelsey
wasn't that hallmark moment, you know,
it's like, oh my gosh, I love
you so much. It was actually,
I was getting rushed in my really one
of my right leg ripped open and they're
like,
Mrs. Mills,
you're in charge of his medical history
now you have to sign this piece of paper.
Um, he has to get two inches
of conference, right leg.
We need your consent consent. And she's
like, what? And she almost passes out in,
they're like, Mrs. Mills. I'm like, Kelsey
just signed the paper and I'm yelling,
just sign the paper.
It's okay.
And she signs and that's the first time
I got to see her. Just real quick. Yup.
Go ahead and hack them up.
And they went and took my leg two inches
off on the right and reseal that next
day is when I tell her like,
you know,
this isn't probably anything
that you signed up for you.
You can go and, you know,
you're not, it's no big deal. I'm not
worried about it. And she's like, nope,
not how this works. We'll get through
this together. And then they, you know,
they induced me into this coma later on
because the pain was so bad and I was
getting my tolerance level built
up for the pain meds. And, uh,
she sat with my bed like 20 hours a day
and not knowing I wasn't gonna wake up
for five days,
we're gonna put them out for five days.
So yeah. So this was crazy. Uh,
reading about in the book, you,
you're in such horrible, horrible
pain, like undescribable pain.
Is this basically an experimental thing
procedure that they did on you? Yeah,
I'm the second in the nation. Never have
the ketamine coma in 30th in the world.
And Sonic case studies on me.
The ketamine coma is 600 mellow
milligrams of ketamine per hour.
Yeah. So it goes around the clock
as well. It is based on that
wait and things. So I'm sure like
different measurements. But, uh, they,
when they did it, you go in and
then it just circulates through.
It's supposed to reset your brain to
think where your nerves is and where they
end and you know, you come out and
it's just loose knit like crazy.
And getting on TV is
what was real life to me.
Yeah, no the, I'll, I'll hit some
highlights from your hallucinate.
Cause when you get,
when you get done out of the coma,
you're in a coma for five days,
which is just black. Nothing, right?
There's no nothing, nothing there. Then
you go into hallucinations. You got um,
chasing kids that stole things from,
you got gangas con that you're out with
Gangas con you're a swat team is coming
to get you.
You got you and your cousins are riding
skateboards in a TV reality show.
You've got yourself playing
hockey in the NHL. Um,
I was particularly concerned about a 50
year old go go dancer that crawled on a
leash down the hallway of Walter Reed.
That one made me a little bit nervous. Uh,
the service dog, apparently
Kramer from Seinfeld stops by. So,
so you go through these massive
hallucinations that that's freaking weird.
Yeah,
I mean it got to the point where I'm
getting on my tangents and they said for
the first like seven days,
you know it's going to be bad.
Then after that it'll start to fade out.
In that 10 days you should be able to
tell when you're having one or not.
But I remember my final,
I'll come in one morning and the caps
game was on the night before and I was
watching it. I was like, I scored
nine goals with Ovechkin vegetarian.
I had a triple hat trick. He's
like, oh that's, that's great.
And then I thought the way I got blown
up when I woke up the very first day,
I thought that this guy from my hometown
made a derogatory comment towards my
mom, my wife, my daughter,
and my buddy's not jumped in the car and
chased him and went off the road and I
smacked a tree and I
killed my two best friends.
And like I made my mom and my wife
like full on. Oh leaved those 100%.
I told my brother and all of the story
just in intently or intense as I told my
wife, and he listens like, oh yeah.
And everybody just going with it.
And so I try to like argue
with me and they're like,
we're just gonna go with this.
And I called them my buddy's a
message and I'm like, I am so I,
I hope you're not dead.
And then I finally came out of his
nation and I realized what happened to my
brother. And I walked back in. I was
like, Hey man, thanks you dick is, well,
I didn't want to tell you any different
when I was like, yeah, no, I understand.
You know, that's like, don't text
when you're drunk or whatever. Yeah.
Don't call people leave messages and
when you're on seven day hallucinate.
Yeah. Trips. And I only left two messages,
but they're two of my best friends.
So it was cool. And both them
was, I'm sorry I killed Judah,
the hey man over on you. I
think I killed you. And, uh,
and then I got to a point where
I get to tell what was going on.
So like I started having another one, um,
and I was like, oh, that's hallucination.
And then finally I get to a
point I was playing with people,
like Josh was in my room and I was
like, Josh, he goes, what? He goes,
I see dead people. I said, what? You're
serious? I'm like, no, I'm just kidding.
I was like, okay. And that's our
looking at the ceiling. I was like, oh,
they're all around me. He's like, w
w where, where? I'm like, oh my gosh,
Josh Turner Ward.
And I like jabbed him.
So I started messing people once I got
the hang of it. Oh, that's awesome. Uh,
and that kind of like did it
though, right? Yeah. Yeah.
So I did about five more months of
pain pills. Um, and then finally,
like in October,
I was home for Thanksgiving in North
Carolina at my house at Fort Bragg.
And I was just like, you know what, Kelsey
came, I was, I don't want him anymore.
I'm done. Just like, you can't just quit
these. And I said, no, I really, I'm done.
So I was like five days of pain and
then now, no medication, nothing.
I'm good to go. So the ketamine
coma and my documentary, you know,
it says I wouldn't do it again,
but that was five months after the fact.
I was still like doing pain pills and
stuff or four months after the fact I
guess, cause they're in September. Um,
but looking back like that was the best,
the best thing for me to get me past the,
you know,
the pain part and then onto my
recovery was a second person that ever
had that done, I guess in the
nation. That's crazy. Yeah. Um,
either there's a great talking about your
kind of transition mentally going back
to the book back in normal days.
I love the challenge.
The quest to succeed in the army
has always been a challenge for me.
My situation now as a quadruple amputee
held out the same sort of dare to
succeed. Sure. If I could
have changed things,
I wouldn't have been in this situation,
but I couldn't change things.
Being a quadruple amputee
was my new reality.
I could quit for good.
I could shut myself off from the world.
I could will myself to die,
or I could fight forward
and keep on living legit.
Well, I mean, it came down to a
choice at the end of the day. Um,
I was still here and my wife's
gonna say by my side, my daughter,
who I think's gonna think I'm a monster,
still laughs.
The snuggles up with me and you know, I
mean, when she first saw me, I thought,
she's gonna be really afraid. But then
short arms, short legs, fuzzy chest,
I looked like a teddy bear. He's
like, oh no, we're totally, you know,
but this one can talk.
Yeah, cool. In their active,
I've never been stern with my mom.
I did write my mom's nose one time,
the whole different story.
Karate.
I know my dad and me were
slap boxing in the kitchen,
which meant I was 17 my dad was trying
to mess with me, but if I slapped back,
you'd be like, Dude, you can
take me. And I'm like, no,
brother. We were just playing.
But he slapped me.
My Mom's behind me.
And I caught the back of my head
and the scariest day of my life, um,
you don't make her mad and, but anyway,
so I was only started one time, my mom,
I woke up, you know, and I suppose to
get all the rest I could and I said,
where's Chloe at? She was like,
oh, they already came to visit,
but you were sleeping. I was like, don't
ever let me sleep through that again.
That's the whole reason that I'm
able to still keep functioning.
It's because of my daughter and you
know, uh, being there and my wife.
But you know,
the mental part was the worst at four
o'clock to eight o'clock at night,
I can have the lights on in my, in
my apartment, something to do with,
I thought it was like the operating
table. I start sweating real bad. I just,
I mean now I'm fine, but it
was the first, I don't know,
probably five to six months. I was
just like, no lights at this time.
It's quiet out work and things like that.
And Man,
I started watching like I watched
a video of you as you are training,
as you are now relearning everything.
I never really understood when people say,
Oh, you got to read, you got to relearn
to walk and you've got to realize,
and I didn't really make sense of it,
but it's really clear to see
when you watch your progression,
what that looked like.
Like how you are clearly relearning how
to walk. Like I never understood that.
But when you watch the videos and
the progression that you made,
you can see that that's what it looks
like when you first stood up. I'm like,
Oh yeah,
it looks like he's learning how to Walker.
And sure enough you got better and better
and it's pretty amazing. And, and uh,
two things you're going to find out. When
I was going through my, uh, recovery,
the first thing I learned how to walk
with my daughter. We're just kind of cool.
They got me little short legs and I was
stumbling around and she was stumbling
around and we're holding hands.
And the next thing you found out,
my love for Philly cheese steaks because
I do less workouts and stuff like that.
The Gym, you know, as you go.
But I went from two 50 to one 40 and I
was real skinny and then all of a sudden
I started getting fatter and fatter
and fatter because the Lyrica and the
medication and I was just like,
oh, I love Philly cheese steaks.
So I'm trying to work on that
now. But my progression as I got
better, I got fat or too embarrassing.
And you got a visit from a guy named Todd
nicely [inaudible] and that must have
helped out a lot. Uh,
my competitive edge did.
He walked in and on his fake legs and to
fake arms and he first thing out of his
mouth was, hey man, welcome to the club.
I was like, I don't be in your club.
Is it kind of late now, don't you think?
And I looked at myself and I said, right,
you got me there? And uh,
as you walked over and said,
you want a ginger ale
and you heard me wrong.
And he went over to the counter or
the sink in our neath. The sink was,
was a 12 pack of Ginger Ale. I got
hooked on it, like crack at the hospital.
I got off it now, but either
way, he bends down on one knee,
bends down on his other knee, reaches
out with his fake hand, gets it out,
pops the top, his other arm and walks
over and hands and he goes, here you go.
I'm like, oh no. I was
asking if you wanted one,
but before I had the full sentence out,
I said, how'd you do that? He's like,
Hey man, I'm Todd and I'm the second ever
welcomed the club. You're the fourth,
a quadruple amputee to make it back home.
You're going to be fine.
I live in Missouri with my wife. I drive,
I have a boat, I do whatever I want.
I walk. It just takes
time. And uh, he's like,
I'll even work out with you
tomorrow. You know, this is like,
I'm still thinking I'm an hallucination
mode. This is like maybe eight,
nine days after my elders, my,
uh, ketamine coma, and he's like,
I'll work out with you tomorrow. So
the doctors come in and I'm like, Hey,
I got to work out today. And they're like,
you can't work out. Yeah. And I was like,
no, no, seriously, I've been in, I'm going
to work out with Todd nicely. He said,
I can work out at one o'clock. And
they're like, well, you're not ready.
And I had to let him know, I was like,
I don't know what you don't get, buddy.
I'm working out today. And
he said, I'll think about it.
So I call them every half hour, four
hour straight to find set. I could.
And I went and met Todd and Todd did a
workout and I laid on my stomach with the
pelvis, a pat [inaudible] are
under my stomach or whatever.
So that stretched my pelvis muscle back
out and he'd pat on the back and I fell
asleep. 20 minutes. Best
workout I've ever done. But, um,
I started my recovery that day. And
then as far as the physical, as easy as,
you know, I like the physical challenge.
The mental was the hardest part for me.
I mean, bar none. It was,
it was the worst. You know,
I couldn't look at myself in the mirror
for a while there because I didn't like
what I saw. You don't see, you
might, my arm's gone. The scars, um,
just the overall message that I was and
I'm thinking now is going to be a burden
and all that. So it just, that's just
how it went. So the more capable you got,
the more comfortable you got
in your new skin. Yeah. Well,
I've found out that they let you go for
one hour and then a physical therapy in
the one hour of occupational therapy
and then they let me do another one and
another one. It turned into
four hours of, of each.
So eight hours put in eight hours
a day at the gym in my recovery.
Well at the gym and occupational therapy,
learning how to use my hands,
how to wash myself again, how to dress
myself again, uh, learn how to drive,
learned how to do all that stuff.
But it took 19 months of at Walter Reed,
13 months in paperwork was after
that to get out. But government,
uh, and you, you, um,
you eventually went and met your guys
when they came though. That's awesome.
I did, I set some goals. Um, when
I was in the hospital, my birthday,
I called my life, my mom and dad
and I was basically really short.
Hey guys was up and find love you.
Bye. That's all I wanted to say.
I didn't want to talk and
have a conversation and go
over what happened to me.
Um, I kept it very short, but
I told my brother and I said,
I have to call my guys in my unit.
You need to find the number to my
strong point and let me talk to them.
So there's a pitcher going around
where I had a baseball cap or no,
I was out on patrol and I had sleeves
rolled up. And a helmet off. Sunglasses.
I mean everything out of
standards as they, as you know,
they have standards or whatever. And I
got ahold of my sergeant major, I said,
sergeant major, I'm so sorry. I
understand if you had to take my rank,
I should have been out of uniform.
I do apologize.
And now the pictures go in public
and he's like, you're crazy dude.
Like just to get better.
You're fine.
And then I got ahold of my guys
and I told them guys, I'm fine.
I'll be okay and I'll be there
when you get back from Afghanistan.
I'll be there at the, you know, the ramp
to give you guys a hug on my tall legs.
And it took me a while. I got my tall
legs that morning when they got back.
I had to work out three hours today
and then the tall legs don't bend,
but like that wasn't wearing now, but
there they make me at least six foot tall.
Well you can't take those legs. Homeless.
She can stand up when you fall down.
So the whole day the therapist's walks
up and says stressful and they knock you
down and you're like, what the
hell? That's not a trustful
I supposed to catch me.
I supposed to close my eyes and trust
you're gonna catch it. And they're like,
that's the catch. You've
got to get yourself back up.
Therapists are great. No,
I had, I had two of the best therapists,
uh, that, that you could ask for.
Now I'm carrying and Joe and that
got me back to where I was at,
but I did meet my guys and the first,
one of the first people I got to hug us,
doc Bateson, you know, and say,
hey man, thanks for all you did.
And then you end up doing a five k
five k run.
So [inaudible] got another goal. Yeah. So
Todd nicely came in and when he met me,
he had four firefighters
also for telling the towers,
five k to do in New York City.
And they also,
they partner with Gary Sneeze and they
build houses and things like that for
guys that have been through traumatic
injuries. And they were like, hey,
we're going to have a five k in
September where we're going and I'll,
we'll push you. I'm like,
I'll walk it. They're like,
wow, yeah, but we'll push you.
It's no big deal. And I was
like, no, you don't understand.
Like I'm just gonna walk it. And
like, well you don't have legs yet,
but if you do walk it,
that's cool.
So I went up to New York City after my
daughter's birthday the day after and
walk the five k, uh, I came out of the
Brooklyn Battery Tunnel Thinking, okay,
I'm going to sit down now.
Like, I'm tired, my back hurts.
I've got a mile, you know,
1.2 miles or something to go my right leg.
I had completely rubbed raw
bleeding inside my socket
and I was like, it's good.
I've, I've met a goal, I've walked
over to, you know, two miles now. And,
uh,
I came out of the tunnel there,
343 firefighters with banners around their
neck for nine 11. I thought, Jeez, okay,
well if those guys and gals can go up
down this flight of stairs and then
ultimately die, um, you know, trying to
save lives, I can finish this. So I did,
I was sore, it was bad,
but I didn't finish it.
And then,
um,
eventually you're like you said you're
driving now you went out and did like
mountain biking and skiing and all this
other kind of just getting after it
basically for better or
for of a better term.
Um, and then you, and then you
retire, you retire from the,
from the army and,
and what's your next move?
Your next move is you figured out you're
going to get a house and you're gonna
move to, I had to move to Maine. My
wife is from Maine originally. Uh,
the heat doesn't do well with amputees
cause your blood circulates faster. You,
it comes back warmer when you
really see it from your body's head,
hands and feet. So I'm missing, you know,
four of the five and then
my legs are capped off.
So if I wear pants or for wear shorts,
it's the same.
There's no air hitting a third
of my body. And uh, yeah. So we,
we decided we're going to move to Maine.
Um,
we didn't start a nonprofit to help with
care packages at first and then we grew
it to the retreat center that
we have here in Maine. And, um,
really through my work at Walter Reed,
when I was at Walter Reed,
I was such an upbeat person as the
same person as before the blast.
I was still going in and having Casha
Fridays cause it made people annoyed,
but other people loved it. Having watched
Friday Kesha Fridays I'd go put my,
take my phone, I turn on cash
on Pandora and we just rock out.
And uh, the reason I unfortunately
saw videos of youth like dancing,
which cannot be on scene, apparently
burned into your retina. You're welcome.
But, uh, you know,
they started to asked me if I'd meet
people upstairs and it started out, hey,
you know, Travis, we have a guy upstairs,
I can't tell you his name or his room
number, but if you could talk to them,
really help, he's not in 41 and he's not
in 43, but if you can find him, you know,
and I'm not a marine, so, you know,
obviously I'm smart enough to find that
there's number 42, I don't eat crayons.
Um, but anyways, so I, uh, would go up and
talk to him. Then that turned into like,
hey, we have PFC Johnson, he's
missing two legs. Um, his mom,
his mother in law and his two
kids are here. Can you go see him?
I told him you'd be up
around this time. And, uh,
that's how the book got started
and my documentary got started.
And then the foundation was just cause
all the nonprofits at Walter Reed doing
great things. Kelsey and I wanted to
give back some way, shape or form.
And this is how we've decided that
we can get back the best. Yeah. So,
um, what, tell tell us
more about the foundation.
So the Travis Mills Foundation was
started really just for care packages
overseas and then I went out to Colorado
or how to go downhill mountain biking
and doing things.
And then I realized that Walter Reed
does a great job of taking the service
member out there. The only thing that
the government, uh, doesn't lack,
but because of the funds
have to go to the soldiers.
They don't get to bring all the families
like my wife got to go cause I needed
assistance and things.
But a lot of the guys that could take
care of themselves couldn't bring their
loved ones and that's fine.
That's okay.
But we thought we could do
something in that, in that space.
My whole reason for getting better,
it was my wife and my daughter easily.
So we started bringing families out.
We did it for one week of a year and we
brought families out and show them how
to do things,
adaptively Kayak and canoe and things.
And then we did another one and
it went so well. We thought, well,
we should buy a property.
So we bought a property,
it's supposed to be a $500,000 project.
Now it's a $3 million project. Uh,
we did our first week of program,
or I mean your first year programs.
This year we did seven weeks, 56
families and we bring them up. Uh,
we host eight families per week up to
40 people and we show them how to do
things.
We have a place on the water for kayaking
and canoeing and tubing and boating
and we just,
um,
the horseback riding and archery and
there's all these activities of ropes
course and we just say, you know what?
I understand what you're going through.
I understand it can get tough. Here's a
network of people that are just like you.
Whether you live in Chicago,
in the inner city,
or you live in the plains and Montana,
reach out,
understand that these families are
going through the same thing. Um,
feel comfortable when you come here
that you can fall out of a kayak and
nobody's going to freak out.
They're going to understand
what you're going through.
And it's just as much of a,
a place for the loved ones.
You know,
the wives that can talk to other wives
or our spouses and the kids can run
around and see the, you know, what my
dad has one leg missing and one arm,
but this dad has two legs missing.
And that's pretty cool because
they know what we're going through.
And after our first year of operations
and running, it was such a great success.
We're going to do strategic partnerships
with other nonprofits that share our
mission and they'll donate what it costs
for a week and they'll run their own uh,
retreats up here as well.
So we're talking to with gold star
member families as well as PTSD and Tbi.
Cause right now I focus on
limb loss or parallelization,
but this hopefully will run 40 45 weeks
out of the year. It's all donation based.
And the cool thing is like
as the president and the
six other board members I do
have, we don't take a dime, we never
will. We're auditing ourselves right now.
So we got on the CFC,
the combined federal campaign
and it's all about giving back.
So it's been really rewarding
and fulfilling and I'm,
I'm glad to be out there helping these
families cope with their situation and
tell them that there's other people
out there like you keep going,
never lived life on the sidelines and
it most importantly never give up and
never quit.
If people want to help this organization,
what's the best way for them to do that?
Visit the website,
Travis mills.org.
It has all the information on the
foundation is wasted. Donate online.
There's ways to do volunteer options.
We had people fly in just to volunteer
for the week and help us out.
And there's also ways to do corporate
sponsorships. We had Wayfair come in,
donate all the furniture, new balance came
in donated to us and things like that.
So we're growing, um, we
believe in our mission.
We know we can do this and there's other
things we want to get accomplished out
here. We need to build a
multipurpose center. Uh,
we have a pool going in and things like
that, but it's all about giving back and,
and,
uh,
the mindset of the service member that
we're trying to host and the family,
the book tough as they come.
That's what we read today. It's a,
it's a great book. I read was
small chunks of it. Um, yeah,
you can pick that up, uh,
anywhere where they sell books.
And what about the documentary?
So the documentary, it's called
Travis, a soldier's story.
It was done in 2014 and it was actually
a unveiled the Gi film festival.
And um, we took first place
and 55 short films. Uh,
I got to meet Marcus and Melanie and
the trail at night. It was really,
really great to meet them. And now Netflix
is signed to on for a two year run.
So we got on Netflix in May, so if anyone
wants to watch that, it's on Netflix.
It's called Travis soldier story. Um,
and it just tells the whole story.
It just has iPhone footage of everything
that Kelsey and I went through. Yes.
And the two medics. Cool.
The two Max saved my life.
I actually are reenacting you getting
blown up and the two guys get hurt are in
the documentary as well.
Yeah.
And my brother in law saw people that
were there or in the documentary?
No,
between the book and watching
the documentary and you
get to see the faces and
everything. It's really, uh, it's
really cool to real powerful. And, um,
what about social media? How's your
social media presence? Mister popular?
It's not yours
by any means.
Uh,
W we're about 60,000 in some
strong on our Facebook page.
I do little videos. Uh, my
daughter learned how to tie
her shoes the other day.
We taught her in the morning and you know,
by like we talked at like 7:00 AM by
nine o'clock. She's tying it by herself,
giving an intro to tying
your shoes online. But just
SSG, Travis mills is my page.
If you want to check it out, share my
story that, that really helps us out.
And it's Twitter, Instagram, and
Facebook. You're on all three. S S,
g Travis mills. That's, that's
where you can find it. Um,
yeah. You know, you,
you put the, the last thing in the
book, like the last line in the book,
you say to live in freedom, to
go forward, to love your family,
to make something of your life, to
never ever give up, to never quit.
Yeah.
That's success. And Yeah,
obviously I'm, in my opinion, if,
if never giving up and never quitting is
the definition of success that I think
you're the most successful person I've
ever met in my life, brother for real.
Well, I appreciate that. I just,
we realized that people
that depend on you,
the people that went into all this
and the lives that are lost. I mean,
you've had a lot of buddies. I'm sure
they didn't make it back home. Um,
my situation is not, not life
ending. My situation is just,
I got a couple more steps in the morning,
put my legs on Palmyra
Amman and take my daughter.
Tomorrow is actually my daughter's
orientation at school. I get to take her,
my wife and I just had
a baby. Um, and I named,
I named our little boy after my
two medics, his named Dax, Dax,
after Daniel Alexander for
the medics that saved my life.
So thankful to still be here, uh, through
all the smoke in the dirt and the dust.
Uh, it's all settled now and, um,
I'm living life to the fullest and doing
the best I can to make sure that people
understand life goes on and to
never ever give up and never quit.
Anything else? Any
closing thoughts? I mean,
I just obviously want to thank
everybody went into this. I mean,
from my unit on the ground, I know I
was a heavy guy, you know, walk around,
wait was 400 pounds. So I'd get, you know,
with all my gear on and all that to
get me out of there was great. Uh,
this medical staff, doctors,
nurses, um, physical therapists,
occupational therapists, everybody, uh,
obviously my family that went into it.
I want to say thanks for
being there with my side,
my beautiful wife and my wonderful
children, um, for, you know,
really accepting what happened and moving
forward in life and just, uh, you know,
thereby no, you know, you
can't always affect your,
your situation you find yourself in,
but you always can affect your attitude.
And that's, that's where
I find the most, uh,
I guess the most realization in
my situation. I can't always,
if I drop something on my hand,
you know,
I can't pick it up right away or I have
to do something weird and get mad about
it because getting mad doesn't, I'm
getting mad, doesn't do anything.
So I always try to keep my head two
positive and keep pushing forward.
But thanks for having me. Also, I want
to thank you for having me on here.
Both the gentleman, I didn't
look at you very much. Oh, sorry.
I know we talked about this earlier,
but he said not, you said not to.
Yeah. Try not to, that's it's
at your discretion for sure.
I've got to Redo this then so I can look
at you more than you. Okay. But perfect.
Perfect. Yeah. Hey man,
thanks for coming on. Um,
of course. Thank you for your
service to this great nation,
not only as a soldier and a
leader on the battlefield,
but for your continued service that you're
doing today for veterans and also for
the, the gift that I think
you give everybody that
hears about you or comes and
contacts you with you in any way.
And that is
just a living example of grit
and of determination and of will.
And
I,
I just think you're the absolute model
of what it means and what people can
accomplish.
Yeah.
If we do, as you say, and
that is to go forward,
never give up and never ever quit.
Thanks for coming on,
Brian. Thanks for having me.
And after a little administrative break,
Travis has left the building
pretty damn awesome.
Yeah. To have him on, man.
Yeah. Um, yeah.
Any and every excuse that a person
might have as a human being just got
destroyed. Yeah. Yeah.
And he really kind of illustrated how
hard it got spread the time when you,
like when he said, oh, I quit in the
hospital. Yeah. And it's Kinda like,
it makes just kind of when you're around
them now and you see just how he is,
it kind of really brings to
light how good he is now. Yeah.
You know,
and,
and he couldn't at that moment in time.
And when people get into that
darkness, they don't see, they,
they can't,
they can't see the future.
They can't see that things are going to
get better. They can't see, you know,
for him at that point in time, there's
no way it was going to get good. Yeah.
You know, so yeah. That's
very true. Very true. Yeah.
Another interesting things that when
you see again where he's like concerned
about his men and even
when he said I quit, he was
concerned about his wife. Yeah.
And like that was the significant element,
just totally selfless person.
Awesome. Um, well
speaking of
being awesome. Yeah. Echo Charles,
you're awesome. We think we can talk
about some awesome American made stuff.
That's a good idea.
I like where you're going with this origin
origin mean.com but yeah,
origin, that's the brand.
So what is origin were
in league with origin?
I liked the expression in league with,
by the way,
I might've told you that before. Yeah,
it's a good way of putting it. Yeah.
So this is straight up.
The Best American made
apparel in the world. You can,
you don't have to say the
best American made apparel.
You can say it's the best apparel in
the world and it's American made. Yeah.
Is that subjective?
I guess it's kind of subjective,
but if you say it's
the best American made,
well I guess it all technically might
be on a, no. Either way is dope.
Yeah. And it's all made in America. But
here's the thing about made in America,
I guess, I don't know, I could
be wrong about this part,
but technically you could be like, yeah,
they, they sewed these, I don't know,
pants or whatever, you know,
in America and be like, Hey,
where'd you get the material? Oh, well,
you know, we got it from somewhere else,
not in America, which I guess
is cool. Technically was made.
It was crafted but not here.
So you figure what like let's
say a cotton pants, right?
You get the material from America,
but how do you make the material, the
actual cotton where it's cotton come from?
You grow it. I used to have a cotton like
trees, like a bunch of them by the way.
I'm quiet nonetheless. So where do
they get, where does origin get that?
Cotton America.
What about the seeds to plant the cotton?
They're from America for sure.
So straight up from the ground.
The earth.
From the seeds to the pants that you
get in the event of you getting pants.
Yeah, the way there's other stuff.
There's geese and now owns a good one.
The geese, if you're into
Jujitsu. Nonetheless, the
pants that I got, the joggers,
he was asking me, how do you like
those? And you know the new joggers,
they're kind of like, they
have a different shape than
the old school sweatpants.
So I was like, okay. You
know, and I looked into those.
I was telling Pete this story where I
ordered some ironically from overseas,
I ordered them from overseas. They
looked pretty good, so I ordered them.
Didn't come in. By the way, this
was about a year and a half ago.
Still didn't come in by the
way, but I looked into it.
I was like, whatever. It is,
probably not for me. Small Attic, you
know, it's a sign one of those deals.
Either way I get pizza once. I'm like,
all right, cool. I'm going to try these.
I put them on
surprisingly legitimate as far as the look
goes. Cool. It's me pee even said that.
I'm like,
I look good in them,
which is a lot cause I just kind of
met Pete in person over the past week.
Anyway, good stuff. Just
saying it's good stuff.
And again, all made in America.
All of it. Uh, some geese on there,
some cool rash guards,
the George Washington Rash Garden.
Then I feel like we're ready for that one
to come back. So yeah. So Pete should,
yeah, Jude have that
one. Yeah. Nonetheless.
Origin main.com and when I say main,
it's the state Maine. So origin m m
m e, I n e.com. That's a good one.
The best one really when it comes down
to it. Also Jocko has some supplements,
Krill oil,
which we need
and joint warfare.
So really this is like a full
on like joint cause Krill oil,
Omega threes four. You're going first of
all, yeah. Then join warfare. It's like,
cause there's a bunch of things
regardless of what you, you think. Yeah.
Crew oil joints, boom. Good. It's, there's
more to it than that. Just like wow.
Like glucosomine could.
It was all like basically all the stuff
that you have been taking for years.
You said, you know what, let me
come over with my own Jocko formula.
Then we have it now. Boom. Have
it now. Two products, right.
Super curled joint warfare.
That's the one that's the kit.
That's the new kit.
As far as kids go also,
those are also an origin
main.com by the way. Yeah. Yeah.
Origin main.com also on it,
so you know,
we've been,
we're on a trip right now in the event
of people not knowing that we're on a
trip to Maine.
I didn't bring the kettlebells.
Okay.
I thought that that, that
might've been too much. Plus,
you know, to check on Kelly,
they give you 50 pounds,
right in your luggage.
My kettle bells one you hit a bump more
than 50 pounds nonetheless. 88 pounds.
Yeah. In your case, minus 62. Okay.
The Werewolf Times 224.
Boom. Math on point.
There was a guy at the camp that we
went to that brought the kettle bells,
the 70, whatever one. The guerilla
one from on it. The cool one.
I didn't, I didn't work out with them
though. I was gonna I want to do,
I intended to
anyway,
those gorilla and Werewolf
kettlebells that I'm talking about,
these are the cool kettlebells
there from on it. Those are
all kettlebells are good really. But if
you want that level up of coolness, um,
yeah, I get those ones on it.com/jocko.
Get it jump ropes on there.
The bunch of cool fitness stuff.
If you're lagging in your,
which I do. Sometimes I lag in my
work. Not In lag like physically,
but um, interest wise, you know
you get kind of bored, not you.
You don't get bored, Huh? No. You just
like go out. Doesn't matter. Right.
It doesn't even register board or not.
Yeah.
Execution is happening to
know what it's about. Yeah.
Well some of us we get kind of bored
and it's not that we're getting bored so
we're not going to do it. We're
looking for something like, Oh yeah,
let me try this new thing,
some new hotness in regards to workouts.
Can you not say new hotness anymore? This
podcast will Smith's it and one of the,
one of them I thought it was cool. It
doesn't like certify it for the podcast.
I know Bri. I figured I'd try it out
though. Just know that it's been tried.
It failed next and rejected, huh? Gotcha.
If you want some new cool stuff to do
in regards to a workout. Hey Man, look,
audit has all these one,
they have battle ropes in Macy's in cool
set and they have cool videos on there.
By the way,
don't get addicted to the website.
Spin appropriate amounts of time
on the website. Not Too much.
Remember how you're talking about like
you know when you watch a video on
youtube and then another one pops up?
Yeah, no, six of them pop up. Yeah.
All all formulated for you.
Especially picked watch out for that
Weird Youtube Munchkins that are like
saying, I know what talent
likes. Yeah, that's actually,
you want to see another street fight
to octa psycho.
Anyway,
just watch out for that.
Aren't on the website on the Onnit
website because they videos are real
interesting. But they're about workouts
though. A lot of them. So it's kind of,
it's kind of a catch 22
video about working out.
Does not replace working out
though. No, no, not at all.
Check and you got to
get after it for sure,
but a lot of options on there anyway on
it.com/chocolate that's the one right
there. Also. You know what
though? In this camp. So
some guys came to the camp,
they brought this 200 pound bag bag of,
he said it was a sandbag,
but it's like gravel and essentially,
and the challenge is
to pick it up over your shoulder, 200
pounds. So even that really, I mean,
that's not that easy. 200 by the way,
when they're explaining it to me,
it was Mike Gerard,
Brian Victor,
they were exploring, explain it to me.
Well, while they're explaining it to me,
I'm thinking,
okay,
I know what 150 pound dumbbell
feels like when you lift it up.
And I'm thinking, could I get that? And
that has a handle and balanced by the way.
So I'm like, shoot, do I though, man, I
don't know if I could do that. Could I?
Could I do that? And then they're like,
oh yeah, you know, like I've done it.
And it's like, okay, so
he can be done. Like it's,
it's obviously not like this thing,
you need years of practice or whatever.
So I was like, but man, I don't know.
And then sure enough. So it's, yeah.
When I went and did it,
it was like it was hard.
I failed the first one I
brought you bring it up,
you kind bring it onto your lap.
200 pounds, man. That's not like,
it's like you know how you say when you,
when you pick up a a a person and
they're just dead weight similar to that.
Anyway, boom. Failed the first
time they're cheering me on.
Thanks for that by the way guys.
That helped me and then the second
time I did it it was, it was good.
One of the high points. Anyway,
that was just a side note. Also,
just a bunch of people
don't have to ask me. Yeah,
I did not participate in the challenge. I
have an injured rib. That was that. Yeah.
You've been real happy about that are
still not out of the sheet on your face
man. Yeah, the ribs almost healed.
Thanks Andy. That was Andy. Andy.
Andy did that to my ribs in a way,
and this is,
I think you paid a bigger price than me,
but you messed up my ribbon in
identical way a few months ago. Oh,
you were gonna get a submission on
me and then you hurt yourself. No,
I was trying, I was escaping a submission.
So essentially the same situation,
but instead this time you got the rib
injury instead of the guy that you're
trying to tap out. So yeah, that's
really in a way, good for you. You know,
and I hope we've all learned something
from this whole thing today anyway,
also when you buy this book and you
will and should tough as they come,
tough as they come.
Travis Mills,
get it through our website. That's a good
way to support. I have a little section,
we have a little section
books from the podcast.
Click on there and it'll be by
episode. This is, um, you know,
this is a good way to support click
through there at bringing to Amazon.
Even if you're going to do
any other shopping. Boom.
Even just as good a way to support
that way. Just click through,
get the book. That's a good
way. Small action, big reaction.
Small Click, click one,
two. It's like two more
clicks. Super Swell. Actually
somebody asked me, they said,
hey, does it really help the podcast
to like do the Amazon Click through?
And I said, absolutely, it
really does. And I said, well,
like how much? And I said,
well, it's basically the
way I could describe it.
It's basically the way I could describe
it. Small action, big reaction.
So Yup. You're very right on
that one. Yes. Yep. You know,
I just had a feeling from
the beginning that that was,
that's a good way to put it.
And it is really also
subscribe to the podcast.
It's a good way to support stitcher,
iTunes,
Google play, all these ones that
provide plot, uh, podcasts, um,
just seems,
you know,
it seemed like something that everyone
probably has done already, but you know,
if you haven't subscribed to that one,
that's a good one. If you're in the mood,
leave a review.
That's a good one.
Some good reviews on there already
and thank you guys for doing that.
Very colorful. Would you say colorful?
Is that a good, colorful, creative,
creative? Yeah, that's good. They're
fun to read from time to time.
Also Youtube,
if you liked the video or want to watch
the video version of this podcast,
see what Travis looks like,
see what Jocko looks like,
see what I look like if you're into
that. Um, yeah. Subscribe to the Youtube,
get up and get a little alert when we
upload a video and just watching what we
look like.
There's other things that come from the
youtube channel yet that are not on the
podcast. Subscribe. Yes.
Whether it's a little augmented videos
that you make with your creative, um,
spin on them. Yeah. There's
just straight excerpts. Right.
And then there's deleted
scenes. Yeah. Deleted scenes.
I think I'll put some more on there.
I, there's a few, you know what,
when you kind of go through and I, and I
want, you know, when I edited it right,
so really the edit, the audio
editing process is pretty simple.
You cut off the beginning, you'll cut
off the end, you faded in, you faded out,
done. That's it. Easy. Yeah.
But the parts of that I cut off.
There's some, some nuggets in there.
Interesting stuff.
And you know when you're in the,
in the moment I'm talking to you,
it's just regular.
We're just talking and whatever.
Maybe we're laughing, maybe not.
But when you kind of go back and listen
to it, it's kind of funny. Anyway,
I'll put some on some of
those on there too. So yeah,
if you subscribe to the Youtube Channel
you can watch those. Those are cool.
The excerpts or just kinda
like, um, you know, sharable,
smaller nuggets of Jocko
wisdom, which is cool. I mean,
you know, if you don't want to listen
to the whole podcast just for the thing.
In fact, in fact there was a couple
of people where they're like, yeah,
I listened to those. They, the guy
at the camp, he was like, yeah,
I listen to those excerpts like almost
every day. Yeah. Cause they're like, yeah,
there's a lot of them in there now too.
By the way.
Also Jocko has a store,
it's called Jocko store,
Jocko store.com. There's some shirts
on there if you want to support.
So I'm not saying by shirt, I'm
not saying buy a hat. Got Hats on.
They're now snap back.
Snapped back. My bad.
I thought they were affected was wrong.
You know what the Echo thought it was?
Flex fit.
Trucker hats don't exist yet.
They don't listen to have those in
the world doesn't need them. Yeah,
it almost doesn't make sense.
Yeah. Well maybe, I dunno.
I for real thought they're flexible.
But you know what?
I looked into it and I
realized that the um,
the reason that I thought they're flexible
is because some new hats I'm coming
out with, oh, maybe in a
few weeks they're like,
there are different style of hat and
their flex fit. They look dope too,
by the way. I'll show them to you one day.
Cool. Um, so yeah, I'm not saying, Hey,
I'm not saying, Hey, buy my shirt, my
rash guard or whatever. I'm saying,
go in the store,
Jocko store,
look on their, so check out the
items and if you like something,
get something from hoodies on there.
Some women's stuff, some patches,
which are cool. I've seen a few of
those on people's backpacks. Actually.
They look on a dope. I'm going to, I'm
probably pulling on my backpack. Um,
and you know from others
letting us all know, sometimes
you just think about loud.
Yeah. I'm curious about that.
We will all be looking for,
I'll show it to you when it's
done. Anyway, Jocko. store.com.
That's a good way. Also psychological
warfare who we just talking to them.
Oh Pete? Yeah. Where? Okay.
Basically psycholo psychological warfare.
What is that?
It is an album with tracks Jocko checks
where in your campaign against weakness
meanings. If you're, if
you have goals, like, okay,
so I listen to Jordan
Peterson and he kind of,
he has this thing,
I'm not gonna go like too much into it,
but he has this thing where
it's like, okay, why I don't,
why don't people get what they want?
And so because,
and one of the reasons it's because
they just don't know what that is.
And we kind of don't even if you say,
I want to get better,
better in what Jujitsu?
Cause you can do one pushup a day and
you're technically better technically.
So it's like what do you
mean better and better? How?
Whatever, whatever. So anyway,
back to this psychological, if you
want to, I don't know, lose weight.
You want to wake up earlier and be more
disciplined in these specific ways and
all this stuff. You want to clean
up your diet to clean up your diet.
You've got to avoid junk food.
All this stuff. Junk food.
You get distracted by short term payoffs,
right?
With junk food because junk,
the whole idea of junk food is short
term pay off over longterm payoff,
good diet, longterm payoff, bad
diet, short term path. Anyway,
if you get tempted by weakness,
you listened to the psychological warfare
album or just a track or whatever.
So look, you waking up early in
the morning to four 30 every day.
That's what I'm doing from now on that
one day when you're kind of tired and the
alarm goes off and you're tempted or
compelled to press the snooze it or just
stay in bed, I'll wake up
later, I'll wake up at at noon
just saying some people wake up at noon,
sometimes play this track
called get up and get after it.
I guarantee you won't wake up at noon.
You'll wake up at the assigned time
assigned by yourself. By the way,
100% success rate on that.
If you fail,
if you listen to this and you fail at
your little thing. Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know what to say, but that's
a good one. Psychological warfare.
Jocko Willink. Look for
it. Look into it. Also
get some Jocko white tea.
You can get that on Amazon.
It'll make you be able to um, do
amazing feats of strengths. Sure.
We're with no effort. Barely at
all. Yeah, like the rock bag. Yeah,
the Jocko white tea. Boom. You
nailed it. Easy money. One Hand. Uh,
books, like Echo said, tough as they
come by. Travis Mills, you can get that.
You can also get a book called extreme
ownership that I wrote with my brother
Leif Babin.
It's about combat leadership way of the
warrior can if you want your kid or a
kid that you know to be
stronger, smarter, healthier,
and therefore because they're smarter and
healthier, they're also more confident.
If you want to do that for a kid,
get him a book called
way of the Warrior Kid,
then you can also get the discipline
equals freedom field manual.
Um, it got a little bump the other
day. I don't know. I think, uh,
like in social media I put something out
and it got a little bump and all of a
sudden the delivery dates of people
that just ordered it got pushed back.
So I don't know. I don't know
specifically like what that means,
but I'll tell you this,
it means your daughter now if you want
to get it when it comes out, order it.
If you want that first edition copy,
which is pretty much what you want.
If you need leadership in your world,
which you probably do because that's
the way things get done is through
leadership.
And you need help in that department.
You can contact our leadership consulting
company Echelon Front. It's me,
it's Leif Babin,
JP to know Dave Burke.
You can email us@infoatechelonfront.com
if you want us to come speak or work
with your company. That's
what you do. And finally,
and this is the muster,
we are close to selling it out right now.
I'm the one that's in San Diego, September
14th and 15th. Leadership tactics,
techniques and procedures for business
and life. Get better at everything.
Get registered,
do it now before it sells out.
It might even be sold out by the time
this podcast comes out, but check it out,
see if you can find it.
Um,
see if you can get their extreme
ownership.com and until the monster.
If you do need to communicate with us,
we're actually cruising
on the Inter webs Twitter,
Instagram,
and also do Boccie ball.
Echo is adequate.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink
and to all the military members out
there that are holding the line.
Thank you. And to those
veterans that stood the watch,
especially those that were wounded.
Thank you for giving us our freedom
and two police, law enforcement,
firefighters, EMT tees,
and other first responders.
Thank you for your service and thank you
for keeping us protected from man and
from nature here at home
and to everyone else out there facing
struggles and facing hard times.
Remember,
remember the challenge is that Travis
mills faced and still faces and he faces
those incredible challenges
every minute of every day.
And he does that with tenacity and
positivity and proves without question
that if you never quit
and you never give up,
and you keep moving forward,
the nothing can stop you
from getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.